Wenn ihr wüsstet, wie stressfrei der Anfang dieser Sendung ist. Herzlich willkommen beim Chaos Radio Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Jeden letzten Mittwoch, am Monat von 22 bis 1 Uhr mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit Johnny. Das Thema heute wird heißen Musik im Internet und alles, was dazugehört. Mikrofoncheck machen.
Mikrofoncheck.
Müssen wir jetzt wieder husten?
Check, check, check.
Geht's.
Klingt aber nach Arztesuch.
Jetzt mal ein bisschen hochdrehen hier.
Wenn ihr die Diskussion der letzten halben Stunde vor der Sendung mitbekommen hättet, lieber Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann hättet ihr schon spaßige Momente erlebt und vor allen Dingen interessante. Das werden wir nachher aber wiederholen oder nachholen oder weiterführen. Denn das Thema Musik im Internet, das heute das Thema Chaosradio hier bei Fritz ist, ist ein gewaltiges mit ziemlich vielen Dingen, über die man da streitwürdig und mit vielen, vielen Aspekten. So wie das Leben in echt. Musik kommt heute im Chaosradio von wem?
Von Mix Master Morris.
Mix Master Morris? Bevor wir uns in dieses große Thema......dann....Block.
.because instant communication is short...
So, jetzt darf ich nach dem Intro das nette Herren.
Geht's?
Ausnahmsweise.
Geht. Geht wunderbar. Diese Sendung ist heute auch ebenfalls in Real Audio zu hören. Vielleicht können die Leute im Chat, der übrigens zumindest im www.www.fritz.de.slash.speakers zu finden ist. Vielleicht können die ja den anderen sagen, die nicht in Berlin oder Brandenburg sitzen, wo das zu finden ist, nämlich unter www.fritz.de.slash.fritz. www.fritz.de.slash.fritz.ram. Das linkt dann direkt zu einem Real Audio File und dann kann man diese Sendung hören.
Genau, wenn alles klappt.
Man kann aber auch das Radio anschalten.
Man kann auch einen anderen Chat nehmen, übrigens. Unser Chaos Classic Chat ist auch offen unter www.ccc.de. Da geht man nicht hin mit Netzgeb-Browser, sondern dann geht man hin mit ordentlich Telnet. Wenn ich weiß, was das ist, dann nehme ich die anderen Browser.
Wer sind heute hier vom CCC?
Heute ist der Tim, der mal wieder dabei war.
Deini ist auch mal wieder dabei.
Und Felix und Steini und Tim und Johnny am Mikrofon. Bevor wir loslegen mit Musik im Internet, werden wir ein bisschen Updates machen. Selten sind so viele E-Mails gekommen, die zu einem großen Thema, nämlich zum Thema Internetstrike am 1. November 1998. Wir machen gleich ein bisschen Musik und dann haben wir ein Interview zu hören mit der Telekom zu diesem Streik und ein Live-Telefonat mit dem Menschen, der diesen Streik verursacht bzw. ins Leben gerufen hat, nämlich Thomas von Treichel. Dazu muss ich aber ein paar Nummern wählen. Das machen wir gleich. Dann gibt es ein bisschen CCC-Updates. Ja, und ich schätze, so nach dem Fritz-Kots-Info legen wir dann los mit der Musik.
Gut, besser hätte ich das nicht zusammenfassen können.
Das folgt mir. Habt ihr auch so viele Mails gekriegt zum Thema Internet-Strike?
Ja, ohne Ende. Also es wird da wirklich fleißig gespendet.
Vor allem ja wirklich unterschiedlich lang. Da noch mal der Aufruf, wer uns Mail schickt, wo irgendwelche Ankündigungen seitenweise krempeln. Einfach nur L schicken, wir lesen das dann schon. Aber 15 mal irgendwie 5 Seiten.
Ihr müsst unbedingt, ihr müsst unbedingt.
Also ein Quot von einem Quot von einer gequoteten E-Mail der Freundin des Freundes des Präsents. Und da dann noch mal 10 mal gequotet und...
Man kriegt doch schwer den Eindruck, dass das wirklich ein... dass es also interessiert ist. Ich dachte irgendwie das erste Mal auch mal wieder so einen Aufruf, wieder so eine Petition und dann haben wir also allein ein Chaosradio, haben wir glaube ich irgendwie 5 mal die Bitte bekommen, das doch bitte zu erwähnen. Dann wollen wir das natürlich jetzt auch tun.
Ja und am Telefon ist jetzt nämlich Thomas. Hi Thomas. Kannst du uns hören? Wir hören euch auch wunderbar. Dich beziehungsweise. Thomas von Treichel ist Initiator des Internetstreiks, der da stattfinden soll am 1. November 1998. Thomas, wo kommst du her, was machst du mit dem Internet? Wie bist du auf diese Idee gekommen und was soll das Ganze?
Also ich komme aus Karben, das ist in der Nähe von Frankfurt am Main. Auf die Idee gekommen bin ich durch einen kleinen Artikel in der Computerwoche, das waren so etwa fünf Zeilen von einem erfolgreichen Streik in Spanien. Es ist ja so, dass die meisten User schon mal drüber nachgedacht haben, dass man irgendwie gegen die Preise unternehmen müsste, aber irgendwie hat halt nie einer die Initiative ergriffen. Und wir haben uns halt einfach gedacht, also ich hab mir in dem Fall noch gedacht, was in Spanien klappt, warum sollte es nicht auch in Deutschland klappen. Hab einfach mal mich ins Internet eingewählt, mal ein bisschen abgecheckt bei den Leuten, wie die Resonanz ist. Und die war schon nicht schlecht. Und dann hab ich gedacht, okay, probier ich mal sowas aufzuziehen. Und dann hab dann innerhalb von etwa zwei Stunden die Aktion auf die Beine gestellt, mit zwei Freunden von mir zusammen, die mit mir eben auch diesen Darkpreis-EV leiten, der ja so ein bisschen Internetzugang gewähren soll für Jugendliche, so ein bisschen Know-how vermitteln soll, weil das Internet ja doch immer wichtiger wird in der heutigen Zeit. Und erreichen wollen wir mit der Aktion einfach niedriger Telefongebühren im Ortstarifbereich. Wie gesagt, das Internet wird immer wichtiger. Wir sind im Zeitalter der Telekommunikation. Und da kann es nicht sein, wenn jugendliche Studenten gerade ständig mit einem Auge am Gebührenzähler kleben müssen, wenn sie für ihre Uni recherchieren, weil sie das Geld einfach nicht haben, um da wirklich ausführlich was zu machen. Das Problem mit dem Internet ist halt, man findet alles, aber es ist nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Und das Geld ist inzwischen mehr.
Und dann halt auch das Geld ist richtig.
Das gibt natürlich, also nochmal gesagt, es gibt eine URL für, man kann sich das also im Netz alles in Ruhe mal durchlesen und Reaktionen auch betrachten. Das Ganze ist zu finden unter www.gamespy.de, also gamespy.spy hinten, slash internetstrike. Und da muss man natürlich dann auch mal mit der Telekom reden. Das wollten wir natürlich live machen, das hat leider nicht geklappt. Die Telekom ist ja bei so öffentlichen Stellungnahmen immer extrem vorsichtig. Unsere Redaktion hat zwei Tage gebraucht, bis wir sie dazu bekommen haben, überhaupt mit uns zu reden über dieses Thema. Das hat Martin Böttcher dann heute nach Mittag geschafft. Er hat geredet mit Jörg Lamis, das ist ein Press der Pressesprecher von der Deutschen Telekom AG. Er hat ihm zu diesem Internetstrike ein paar Fragen gestellt. Die kannst du dir jetzt auch erstmal anhören, die Antworten Thomas. Dann können wir noch ein bisschen plaudern.
Hat sich die Telekom die Aktionen angesehen im Netz?
Ja, selbstverständlich. Wir haben ja auch direkt ein E-Mail bekommen von den Betreibern. Und für uns ist es ganz wichtig, über den Verlauf der Aktionen einfach informiert zu sein, weil die Betreiber ja auch dazu auffordern, dass Telekom-Mitarbeiter Hotlines, Call-Centers oder E-Mail-Adressen blockiert werden. Und von daher müssen wir natürlich auch, um unsere anderen Kunden zu schützen, Maßnahmen einleiten.
Wie hoch schätzt die Telekom den Verlust ein? Sollte der Streik tatsächlich von 80 Prozent der Surfer unterstützt werden?
Wir schätzen den Verlust. Die Insertionen reden so von ca. 10 Millionen Mark. Das ist halt mir für extrem zu hoch gegriffen, weil der Durchschnittslutzer ist gar nicht so lange im Netz. Man muss einfach mal ganz klar sehen, wo die Aktion herkommt. Die Insertionen sind Spieler und Spieler bleiben einfach sehr, sehr lange im Netz. Und ich glaube, wenn hier die Nutzer von 10 Millionen Mark reden, haben sie auch vor allem Spieler im Blick. Ja, selbstverständlich. Also wir haben uns auch gleich informiert und haben festgestellt, dass die Aktion in Spanien nicht vergleichbar ist mit der in Deutschland aus dem einfachen Grunde, weil die spanische Telefonika hat vor kurzem die Kosten fürs Internet deutlich erhöht, um über 100 Prozent für eine Stunde Internet und sich eine starke Belastung für die Internetnutzer, während unsere Internetpreise in den letzten drei Jahren stark nach unten gegangen sind. Ich will Ihnen das kurz an einem Beispiel erläutern. Wir haben, als wir 1995 anfingen mit dem Internet, einen Tier-Online-Preis gehabt von 9, 60 Mark, liegen jetzt bereits bei 3 Mark pro Stunde und haben heute in das Grundentgelt von 8 Mark sogar noch zwei Freistunden integriert. Also gerade mit dem heutigen Tag, wir haben es heute angekündigt, das wird wirksam werden zum 1. November, mit dem heutigen Tag quasi haben wir eine weitere Preissenkundigung angekündigt, also eine weitere Verbesserung gerade für unsere Internetkunden.
Aber diese Preissenkundigung, das war jetzt keine Reaktion auf den angekündigten Streik, oder?
Nein, das war keine Reaktion auf den Streik, keine direkte Reaktion, aber natürlich einfach ein Beleg dafür, mit dem wir zeigen, dass unsere Preise eben stark nach unten gehen, gerade für die Internetnutzer.
Ist denn Erfolg der Streikaktion denkbar?
Ja, denkbar ist vieles, aber ich glaube nicht an einen Erfolg der Streikaktion, einfach weil die Verhältnisse in Deutschland völlig anders sind als in Spanien. Da kommt die Idee her, wie gesagt, in Spanien gab es eine Verteuerung, eine Starkverteuerung und werden bei uns die Preise sehr, sehr stark nach unten gehen. Und ich glaube, dass unsere meisten Kunden das durchaus sehen.
Was kann denn die Telekom noch dagegen tun sozusagen, wegen den Streik?
Ja, was wir auf jeden Fall tun, ist, dass wir bereits vor langer, langer Zeit einen Optionstarif angeboten haben, den ist die Plus-Tarif. Und es ist ganz interessant zu sehen, dass die Spanier, die spanische Telefoniker, genau mit so einem Tarif auch reagiert hat, denn die haben auch ihren Nutzern die Möglichkeit gegeben, dass sie vorab Tarifeinheiten kaufen und auf diesem Wege eine Ersparnis von 50 Prozent erreichen. Genau das ist die Grundidee von CD+.
Soweit Jörg Lamis, Pressesprecher der Deutschen Telekom AG, noch einmal beim Internet-Streik geht es darum, dass am 1. November dieses Jahres alle das Internet nicht benutzen sollen. Das ist ein Sonntag und man soll einfach sich nicht einwählen, kein Internet benutzen und möglichst, falls man eine Homepage hat, auf dieser Homepage als Startseite, als einzige Seite eine Streikseite haben. Auch die kann man unter www.gamesby.de slash Internet-Streik sehen. Und Thomas von Treichel, Initiator der Aktion des Am Telefonen, was sagst du denn zu der Telekom Reaktion?
Also ich weiß im Moment gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Dieses Interview ist eigentlich wieder das beste Beispiel, dass die Telekom entweder nicht versteht oder die Sachen so verdreht, dass sie am Ende wieder positiv für sie dastehen. Ich fange einfach mal die Sachen an, die ich noch weiß. Ich denke, der erste Vorwurf war, dass wir aufgerufen haben, Hotlines und E-Mail-Adressen zu blockieren. Das ist in der Form nicht richtig. Wir haben explizit gesagt, man kann, denke ich, gewisse Nummern anrufen, zum Beispiel mit Sicherheit die Gebühren-Hotline, die für sowas ja zuständig ist. Des Weiteren sind auch Telekom E-Mail-Adressen normalerweise dafür da, Kritik und Anregungen entgegenzunehmen. Ich denke, das sind Kritiken und Anregungen. Wir haben explizit auf die Seite geschrieben, kein Mail-Spamming. Wir haben gesagt, wenn jeder User da einmal hinschreibt, was er von dieser Aktion hält, dann langt das und ich denke, das ist einfach nur ein Zeichen für die Telekom, wie stark das Ganze unterstützt wird. Das nächste war, dass wir aus dem Spielerbereich wären. Das ist in der Form auch nicht richtig. Ich bin kein Spieler und ich habe trotzdem weit über 200 Mark Telefonrechnung im Monat und ich kenne jede Menge Leute, die auch keine Spieler sind. Für den 10 Millionen Mark, die basieren auf einer Rechnung des Geschäftsberichts 1997 der Telekom. Das heißt, da die Telekom auch drauf kommen, können auch diese Zahlen, wenn sie mal nachgerechnet hätte. Dafür, dass in Spanien die Situation etwas anders war, stimmt insofern, dass eben die spanische Telefongesellschaft Gebührenerhöhungen angekündigt hat. Das Ganze geschah bei uns vor zwei Jahren auch und zwar massiv, nämlich weit über 100 Prozent im Ortstarifbereich. Damals sind die User stillgeblieben, weil sie auf die Liberalisierung des Telekommunikationsmarktes gehofft haben, die Liberalisierung ist eingetreten. Es ist leider nichts passiert, also probieren wir es jetzt so auf dem Weg. Das nächste war, dass er erzählt hat, T-Online wäre so billig geworden. Das ist wunderbar. Um T-Online geht es überhaupt nicht. Was T-Online kostet ist in dem Moment ganz egal. Es geht um die Telefonkosten. Ich meine, T-Online ist einer der teuersten Anbieter, Online-Anbieter, das ist noch mal so am Rande, wobei die Telekom es auch da immer wieder versteht, sich billig zu rechnen. Sonst hätten sie nicht so viele Kunden. Aber wie gesagt, es ist schön, dass die um knapp 60 Prozent gefallen sind, aber es interessiert in dem Fall überhaupt nicht. Genauso wie die zwei Freistoßen.
Thomas, ich glaube, dass wir jetzt tierisch viel gehört haben zu dem Thema und sollten unsere Hörer und Hörerinnen einfach auf deine Page schicken, damit sie sich da informieren und diesen Streik unterstützen, so wir ihn unterstützen wollen natürlich. Und ich denke, dass wir in der nächsten Sendung, die ja immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat ist, da vielleicht auch noch mal kurz telefonieren oder auf jeden Fall noch mal einen Zwischenstand geben, wie es dann aussieht, weil das ist dann ein paar Tage vor diesem ersten November.
Darf ich noch kurz zwei Sitzelzins für die Plus sagen, dann bin ich auch eh fertig.
Klar.
Dürfen wir eigentlich auch was sagen? Johnny, du entwendest uns schon wieder unsere Rachel Sendung hier.
Wir machen kurz eine Online-Abstimmung, wer...
Was soll man denn eigentlich noch sagen? Wir können ihm nicht sehr viel hinzufügen, du hast natürlich vollkommen recht. Und ehrlich gesagt, das ist alles nur noch eine maßlose Untertreibung, was die Telekom da irgendwie erlaubt. Das ist einfach unglaublich. Die haben irgendwie jede Bodenhaftung schon immer nicht gehabt. Und die Preise, die sie daneben reißen, also nicht nur die Jugendlichen, aber auch Riesengrund und Boden, da gibt es da nicht sehr viel anders.
Ja, ich red jetzt noch zwei Worte, weil das ist so der Rabatt, auf den sich die Telekom ja immer beruft. Dieser City Plus wird von uns als Pseudo-Rabatt bezeichnet. Und zwar einfach aus dem Grund, weil er zwar bis zu 50 Prozent spart, aber in der Zeit von neun Uhr morgens bis 17 Uhr abends. Und welcher Arbeitnehmer oder Student kann da schon vernünftig surfen. Und ab dann spart er fast nichts mehr, weil ab 21 Uhr gilt er überhaupt nicht mehr und an Wochenenden gilt er auch nicht.
Gut, da kriegt man übrigens auch mehr Infos auf deiner Seite. Da ist das alles nochmal detailliert aufgelistet.
Genau, das ist auch mit Rechnungen belegt. Und da sind auch immer die aktuellsten News drauf, wer uns da jetzt also noch zusätzlich unterstützt und was sich in der Presse tut.
Und ich denke, es werden noch ein paar mehr werden durch diese Sendung.
Ich hoffe es.
Okay, Thomas, ich dank dir und viel Erfolg. Bis denn. Jo, und ich denke mal, dass Thomas jetzt den Rest der Sendung dann Ferris Audio hören kann und wird, wenn er seinen Rechner wieder gebrutet, zu verfolgen. Wir lassen uns hier gar keine Zeit mehr machen gleich weiter. Wir sind schon wieder völlig hinterher, schon gerade mal 20 Minuten vergangen und sind völlig hinter der Zeit. Der Internet-Strike, mehr darüber www.gamesby.de slash Internet-Strike. Aber es gibt auch zum CCC einige Updates.
Genau. Ja, wir schütteln hier noch mit dem Kopf. Also diese Telekomaten, die sind ja wirklich unglaublich. Also die haben auch, als wir 1995 mit dem Internet angefangen haben, was ist denn das überhaupt für ein Satz?
Damit meint er die Telekom.
Ja, ja. Natürlich meint er die Telekom. Ich meine, irgendwie, die konnten nämlich 1994 das Wort wahrscheinlich noch nicht wirklich schreiben.
Und Zynika meint, dass die auch heute noch nicht mit dem Internet angefangen haben?
Die verstehen das wirklich nicht. Also ich bin halt zutiefst von überzeugt, dass irgendwie die allermeisten Leute, die da die Fäden ziehen, einfach noch überhaupt nicht wissen, worum es geht. Ich meine, allein die Abwesenheit von ordentlichen Preisen für Standleitungen und so, also eine ganz klare Ausnutzung ihres Monopols. Sie haben auch die Preise erhöht. Also diese Aussage, die er da trifft, so klar, hier online wird irgendwie immer billiger, von super teuer bis etwas weniger als super teuer. So, aber grundsätzlich, sie haben den City-Tarif irgendwie deutlich erhöht, die Ortstarif, also genau da, wo im Prinzip derzeit die Kohle gemacht wird. Und die sollen sich einfach mal in die Nase fassen, Frechheit. Und vor allem die einzigen paar Standleitungen, die man vorhin nämlich noch halbwegs günstig bekam, das haben sie dann alles irgendwie schön, ne und so, das bieten wir jetzt nicht mehr an und so.
Eine Sache, die vielleicht noch erwähnenswert ist, inzwischen ist es anderen Provalern auch möglich geworden, innerhalb Deutschlands Einwahl zum Ortstarif zur Verfügung zu stellen. Aber wenn man sich überlegt, dass das der Punkt ist, wo die Telekom einfach am meisten Kohle macht, dann ist das nicht wirklich als Vorteil zu bezeichnen, dass jetzt auch andere Internetprovaler zum Ortstarif Einwahl haben. Das heißt, auch da verdient die Telekom kräftig mit.
Und sie sind trotzdem...
Und hier von Einsparung zu reden ist einfach...
Die anderen sind dann teilweise trotzdem noch billiger als die Telekom. Obwohl sie zusätzlich diese Kosten noch mittragen müssen.
Ist ja auch nicht weiter schwierig. Nein, aber hier von Einsparung zu reden, ist im Grunde nur Altsionismus zu bezeichnen. Und der Telekom ist zu raten, dass sie das dann noch mal machen können.
Von daher kann man auch echt nur dazu aufrufen, dass man sich für den ersten Elften irgendwie mit seiner Freundin verabredet oder was weiß ich, ins Kino geht.
Schon wieder ein Jahr rum.
Lasst uns mal was machen zusammen. Können wir mal ins Kino gehen. Genau. Wir haben Mittagsvorstellung. Also, erste Elfte ist ein Sonntag. Ein Tag ohne Internet schafft man schon mal, glaube ich.
Ich denke auch.
Also ich denke, dass... Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei Fritz aussieht. Ich hab mit Lutz noch nicht geredet, aber ich glaube, es werden einige Leute unterstützen. Außerdem ist das ein bisschen Solidarität zeigen im Netz, auch eine schöne Sache.
Genau.
Macht ja auch Spaß.
Die Community-Gedanken hochzuhalten. Da bemühen wir uns natürlich auch immer wieder.
Genau. Schatz, kannst du so zwei, drei super wichtige Sachen in zwei Minuten sagen? Nein, komm, die Meldung des Jahres.
Die Meldung des Jahres.
Tim, jetzt bitte lass ihn hier drin.
Naja, also wir machen wie jedes Jahr auch dieses Jahr wieder einen Kongress, den Chaos Communication Kongress, der traditionell immer vom 27. bis zum 29. Dezember, also zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester, ja, ihr habt richtig gehört, stattfindet. Bisher hatten wir am 14. Mal diesen Kongress durchgeführt, davon fand er 13. Mal in Hamburg statt, einmal in Berlin und dieses Jahr wird er auch wieder nach Berlin ziehen. Das heißt, dieses Jahr ist der Chaos Communication Kongress in Berlin. Die ganzen Details dazu werden gerade ausgearbeitet und werden Ende dieser Woche auf unserer Website zu finden sein. Wir hoffen natürlich auf eine richtige Beteiligung und wir haben auch eine neue Mailingliste dafür eingerichtet. Das kann man auch auf unserer Website sehen, die heißt Chaos Update. Und wenn man sich da eintragen lässt, dann kriegt man alles, was zum Kongress demnächst gepostet wird. Das wird nicht wenig sein, schön in die Mailbox gehoostet. Ansonsten haben wir auch noch hier nächste Woche eine schöne, lustige Veranstaltung. Die C-Base, dieser andere Computer Club, den es hier gibt, die machen so eine einwöchige Veranstaltung. Die heißt ATC Terra. Das fängt am 2. Oktober an und geht dann eine Woche. Und an dem nächsten Donnerstag, also nicht morgen, sondern am 8. 10. werden wir da auch einen kleinen Teil übernehmen und zwar eine Live-Hacking-Session durchführen. Das nennen wir Linux Deathmatch. Felix, du kannst ja mal kurz was zu den Spielregeln sagen, was wir da also veranstalten werden.
Genau, also die Idee ist, dass wir vier Linux-Rechner hinstellen mit grottig alten Distributionen, die noch alle Möglichkeiten haben, die hier dokumentiert waren. Und wir suchen vier Freiwillige, die jeder einen Rechner jeweils sich greifen und versuchen dann jeweils die anderen Rechner aufzumachen. Und wir haben Spielregeln definiert, die dafür sorgen, dass es einem nicht einfach gemacht wird, seinen eigenen Rechner einfach zuzumachen, sondern man muss zwei, drei Dienste eben laufen lassen. Und wir werden Live-Buderationen haben, das soll zwei Stunden laufen. Und wir werden eine große Leinwand haben. Und da wird ab und zu dann auch was gezeigt werden. Und der Moderator, das werde voraussichtlich ich sein, wird da Erklärungen abgeben, was gerade passiert. Und wir versprechen uns da viel Spaß.
Du stehst dann da und dokumentierst...
Ich stehe dann da und sage, oh, jetzt sehen wir gerade am Beispiel von Rechner A...
Ah, da werden gerade Zugriffsrechte verteilt, die gar nicht verteilbar sind und so.
Genau so.
Super.
Aber man muss dazu sagen, ich glaube, geeinigt hatten wir uns auf den SUSE 5.3 oder so. Hier nochmal ganz konkret der Aufruf. Wir brauchen echte, wirkliche Cracks im Bereich Linux. Echte Könner. Da geht es nicht um Spielkram und auch, komm, wir hacken mal ein bisschen, sondern da geht es ans Eingemachte. Vier Stück, die brauchen wir, die sollen sich melden. Das finden Sie auch auf unserer Website www.ccc.de. Da gibt es dann mehr zu und die sollen sich melden. Vier Stück haben die Chance, sich dagegen einander bzw. gegen uns zu messen. Die werden wir vorher auswählen. Nur entscheidend ist, dass in der kurzen Zeit sich jetzt tatsächlich echte Könner einfinden sollen.
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen, ich fürchte, wir haben gerade alle Leute, die sich das auch nur mit halbem Herzen überlegt haben, abgeschreckt, die gesagt haben, wir wollen mal echte Profis haben. Also wenn ihr so ein bisschen gut seid, könnt ihr das ja auch überlegen und einfach mal mitkommen. Und wenn da zu wenig da sind, dann nehmen wir halt aus dem Pool der Zuschauer.
Genau, auf jeden Fall wird es Spaß, da dazu zu schauen. Das könnt ihr dann halt in der Seabase, in der Oranienburger Straße 2, im Mitte am Hackischen Markt.
Ansonsten mehr Info unter www.ccc.de beziehungsweise zum et cetera et cetera, gibt's dann unter www.seabase.org, ist das nicht?
C-Base.
Achso, die Rechner müsst ihr nicht selber mitbringen, die stellen wir, die sind alle gleich konfiguriert.
Ihr könnt aber eure Rechner auch selber mitbringen, das ist bestimmt lustig zu sehen.
Nee, nee, nee, das machen wir nicht. Vier gleiche Rechner, gleich identisch konfiguriert.
Ich kann an einer Kardrope abgeben dann.
Gegen Gebühr, ja.
Oder verschenken oder mit dem Hammer drauf hauen.
Genau, so rennen wir entgegen. Alles sowas.
Und jetzt erst mal dies hier.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Ten, es ist 22.31 Uhr.
Reaktion. Der Weltsicherheitsrat wird morgen zu einer Dringlichkeitssitzung über die Situation in der Krisenprovinz Kosovo zusammenkommen. Hintergrund sind jüngste Berichte über Gräueltaten an Albanern. Schulterschluss. Deutschland und Frankreich wollen nach dem Machtwechsel in Bonn neuen Schwung in ihre Zusammenarbeit bringen. Bei seinem Antrittsbesuch in Paris vereinbarte der künftige Bundeskanzler Schröder mit Staatspräsident Chirac die Bildung von Arbeitsgruppen zur Europapolitik. Terror. Unbekannte haben im jüdischen Teil von Hebron einen Anschlag auf einen israelischen Armeji verübt. Mehrere Soldaten wurden verletzt. Beschluss, das Bundesamt für Strahlenschutz hat einen generellen Einlagerungsstopp für das Atommüll-Entlager Morseleben in Sachsen-Anhalt verfügt. Es reagierte damit auf die Entscheidung des Magdeburger Gerichts, das einer Klage der Umweltverbände Greenpeace und BUND entsprochen hatte. Anschlag. Die Pannen bei der Eröffnung der neuen ICE-Hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke Berlin-Hanover sind durch einen Anschlag verursacht worden. Nach Angaben des Bundesgrenzschutzes wurden auf die Oberleitungen in der Nähe des brandenburgischen Ortes Wustermark zwei Hakenkrallen geworfen.
Wette.
Heute Nacht aufkommender Regen bei 11 bis 8 Grad, am Tage weiterhin regnerisch, Temperaturen 10 bis 13 Grad.
Verkehr.
Stadtautobahn Berlin, Tempelhof Wedding zwischen dem Kreuz Wilmersdorf und Kurfürstendamm Schwarzbacher Straße sind wegen einer Baustelle bis 5 Uhr in Richtung Nord die linke und mittlere Spur und in Richtung Süd die linke Spur gesperrt.
Deswegen war ich vorhin so spät hier übrigens, das war ein Fritz-Kurz-Info mit Pia Kötterheinrich.
Fritz präsentiert ein E-Werk-Event. Indian Summer Rave mit Westband, Takio Ischino, Ape Duke, Steve Barkley, Dole und anderen auf zwei Dancefloors. Indian Summer Rave, Samstag, 3. Oktober im Seegarten Club der Eisenbahner in Brandenburg-Kirchmöser.
So heißt diese Sendung Chaos Radio der Computer Blumen bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club mit Felix, Steini und Tim heute und mit Johnny am Mikrofon als derjenige, der ab und zu die Mikros zumacht. Und auf blöde Zwischenfragen stellt solche Geschichten. Musik im Internet ist das Thema.
Springen wir gleich rein?
Ja, direkt ins Internet.
Dieses Geräusch, was wir im Jingle haben, dieses Einwählen, das wird man auch irgendwann nicht mehr kennen. Das ist so wie das Testbild im Fernsehen. Das wird auch irgendwann verschwinden.
Ja, das wird dann wahrscheinlich so ähnlich laufen wie mit diesen Türen und Motor-Sounds beim BMW. Da bauen sie irgendwann extra noch mal Lautsprecher in die ESD-Karten an, damit man dieses Gefühl noch hat.
Naja, in zehn Jahren hast du das im Museum. Da sieht man dann diese lustigen Dinger, riesig groß, gigantische Kläpper.
Ich denke, überhaupt dieser Begriff Einwählen gehört einfach zu diesen Begriffen, die wir irgendwie in diesem Jahrtausend verbleiben lassen sollten, weil es gibt einfach nix anderes als eine Standleitung.
Ich bin auf die ersten Wohnungsanzeigen gespannt, wo gleich drin steht.
Gibt's schon?
Weiß ich nicht. Kabel, Blah, Internet, Standleitung. Jaja, gibt's schon.
Gibt's doch, da hinten an der Friedrichstraße gibt's schon ein komplettes Haus. Richtig. Ach du denkst an jetzt so eine Wohnung. Ja, gibt's unter Garantie auch schon.
Also in Deutschland noch nicht.
Da sagt mir aber jetzt nur mein Bauch.
Da wird doch frecherweise in der Nähe vom hakischen Markt irgendwie noch VIP-Wohnungen gebaut. Vielleicht so dachte, sag mal, geht's euch noch gut? Die haben auch bestimmt eine Standleitung.
Die WBM plant das auch gerade, die führen das gerade durch mit einer Company zusammen, da auch Mietwohnungen mit Internet auszustatten.
Ich bin ja der Meinung, dass wir dann auf Standleitungen nachts im Web einfach mal ein Aquarium irgendwo einblenden sollten, damit man einfach dieses Feeling nicht verloren geht. Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die sollten dann noch erhalten bleiben.
Aber Internet einwählen, das ist so wie in Norwegen Fisch kaufen. In Norwegen Fisch hat man.
Wir werden in den nächsten zweieinhalb Stunden hier eine Menge Gespräche führen, euch eine Menge Sachen erklären und natürlich dann nachher auch noch mit euch diskutieren zum Thema Musik im Internet. Wir werden euch zumindest jetzt im Radio, man kann ihn ja nicht sehen, aber den M-Player vorstellen und nachher mit jemandem telefonieren, also ein Walkman für MPEG 3 Sounds, der in eineinhalb Monaten auf den Markt kommt. Wir werden mit dem Fraunhofer Institut telefonieren. Wir haben die beiden Macher von Moveabit hier im Studio, einer der zwei, drei Music-on-Demand-Anbieter, die es in Deutschland bisher gibt, die es versuchen. Und wir werden euch natürlich viel Technik bieten. Und ich glaube, mit der fangen wir dann auch an. Ich glaube, jeder, der sich mit Musik im Netz beschäftigt, dem sagt MPEG 3 was. Da haben wir auch schon mal im Chaosradio drüber berichtet. Also das, was man sich zum Beispiel so hin und her schiebt im Netz auf diversen Seiten oder mit diverser anderer Software als dem Browser. Das heißt also Songs in CD, in subjektiver CD-Qualität, so wird ja immer geschrieben, das ist alles im MPEG 3-Verfahren kodiert. Das bedeutet eine Kompression von 1 zu 12 im Gegensatz zu normalem CD.
Das ist einstellbar.
Ohne, ja, es ist einstellbar. Also ich würde vielleicht auch gerne nur kurz noch ein bisschen weiter ausholen, damit das nicht jetzt nur an diesem MP3-Ding hängen bleibt. Generell ist ja eigentlich mit der CD dieses Zeitalter der digitalisierten Musik eingeläutet worden, dass also der Sound eben nicht mehr analog mit irgendwie Höhe von Rille auf Schallplatte irgendwie übertragen wird, mit viel Knistern und Geräusche, sondern das sozusagen zunächst einmal vor der Distribution dieser Digitalisierungsschritte steht.
Obwohl, soweit darf man da nicht gehen, wenn du mal Nachrichten mit Wheel Audio gehört hast, dann weißt du Knistern und Rauschen gibt es immer noch.
Ja, gut, da kommen wir ja, aber der Grund ist ein anderer, so. Gut, und die CD hat ja, wie man ja heute merkt, wenn man so eine Multimediascheibe da irgendwie in seinen Computer rein steht, da passt ja eine Menge drauf. Da ist irgendwie stundenlang Sound und Bilder und Programme und was da nicht alles noch von runter gesuppt kommt. Und da wundert man sich eigentlich, dass man irgendwie vorher da nur eine Stunde Musik drauf bekommen hat. Und der Grund war halt ganz einfach der, dass die CD zunächst einmal zwar digital war, aber eben noch nicht mit Kompressionstechniken daher kam. Das lag einfach daran, dass dieser Software-Bereich noch sozusagen am Anfang war. Da musste man überhaupt erst mal diese digitale Welt da den Programmierern näher bringen. Aber die haben halt schon dran gearbeitet. Und die Idee, überhaupt vorhandene Daten auf weniger Daten abzubilden und trotzdem noch die gleiche Menge an Daten übrig zu behalten, so die musste ja auch erstmal in die Köpfe. Grundsätzlich sollte man zwei Kompressionsverfahren unterscheiden. Das eine sind die, die man so bei Downloads von Programmen kennt, so SIP und dieser ganze Tralala, wo halt nur eine sehr geringe Kompression im Prinzip erreicht werden kann, weil die ursprünglichen Daten zu 100 Prozent erhalten bleiben müssen. Und dann eben die Kompressionsverfahren, die angewendet werden, um Musik oder Video auch zu komprimieren, weil da ist so ein gewisser Verlust nicht unbedingt so schlimm. Die Bandbreite, die CD hat so, das kann das menschliche Ohr gar nicht alles hören, was da tatsächlich drauf ist.
Wobei das natürlich, die werden wir nicht anfangen, die Diskussion, aber das ist eine subjektive Sache. Ich finde nach wie vor, dass eine Schallplatte besser klingt als eine CD und das hat auch Gründe.
Aber das sind aber die gleichen Gründe, auf wie sie kommen.
Ich möchte ja auch gar nicht davon, dass es besser klingt. Diese Digitalisierung, die bringen einfach eine eigene Qualität mit sich, weil eben die Distribution der Musik auf einmal eine ganz andere ist. Na gut, es wurde dann in den 80er Jahren so eine wichtige Wissenschaftlergruppe ins Leben gerufen. Das war die MPEG-Gruppe, das heißt Motion Pictures Expert Group. Sieht man schon, dass es ursprünglich da eigentlich mal um Filme ging, aber da ja auch Filmetone haben, musste zwangsläufig auch Audio bearbeitet werden und die haben sich da über mehrere Jahre irgendwie den Poll gemacht und sich sehr viele lustige Standards haben einfallen lassen, die halt dazu geführt haben, dass es jetzt Algorithmen gibt, also Software, die einen Audiostrom nimmt an digitalen und die gleiche Höherqualität rausbringt nur mit sehr viel weniger Daten.
Und da gibt es eben da verschiedene Stufen, das ist ja Audio-Layer, Kompressionsstufen innerhalb des MPEG-Standards 1, 2 und 3, die sich mit der Zeit so entwickelt haben und – Ich sagte derzeit – das war ja derzeit, genau, da kommen wir noch drauf, 1 war, da weiß ich jetzt gar nicht so genau – Also angefangen hatte ich mit der Audiokompression 87, wo ich recht informiert bin, also schon eine Weile her, aber ist bei weitem noch nicht so lange her wie die Erfindung oder die Einführung der CDs und deswegen war damals auch noch keine Kompression da, weil man erst später gemerkt hat, dass man das eigentlich haben möchte. Und die Layer 3-Sachen sind jetzt sehr bekannt geworden, weil eine subjektive magische Schranke einfach gefallen ist, dadurch, dass man ein 3-Minuten-Lied in 4 Megabyte auf der Platte haben kann und Platten sind halt auch gleichzeitig schön billig geworden und wenn ich mir heutzutage eine große Festplatte kaufe oder was noch moderner ist, ein CD-Brenner vielleicht gleich, da kann ich dann für ein Rolling 4 Mark bezahlen und da kann ich dann ganz viele CDs unterbringen. Also je nach eingestellter Kompressionsrate, habe ich da so 10, 15 CDs schon auf meinem Rolling gebrannt und da kann ich dann schon mal eine ganze Weile mit Musik hören.
Genau, wenn es Hörspiele sind, dann geht das bis 40, 50 CDs, die man wirklich auf eine CD rauf kriegt, weil eben für Sprache die Kompression viel besser sein kann beispielsweise. Also auch das leistet dieser MPEG-Standard. Vielleicht mal eine zu differenzieren. MPEG Layer 1 war jetzt eine einfache Kompression nach üblichen Verfahren. Also man speichert nur die Differenzen und man versucht eben nach bestimmten, doch so war das, er runzelt. Aber Andreas müsste das jetzt natürlich wieder perfekt, der hat mir heute keine Zeit, der muss nämlich umziehen. Also soweit ich das weiß, wollen wir nichts falsches erzählen, werden da nur die Differenzen gespeichert und eben da die Redundanz noch ausgenutzt. Das heißt, kleine Sachen werden immer zusammengepackt mit kleinen Werten. So, dann kam Layer 2, da vielleicht zur Bandbreite, 192 Kilobit liefert da ein sehr gutes Signal. Das ist das, was ADR Digitalradio über Astra heute zum Beispiel verwendet.
Also bei gleicher höher Qualität, wie man es von der CD kennt.
Wie man es so gewohnt ist. Auch da streiten die Profis.
Man kann ja vielleicht mal sagen, wie die Leute zu solchen Aussagen kommen. Und zwar Kompression klingt so, als wenn sich da ein Profin setzt und ein halbes Jahr nachdenkt und dann kommt eben eine Kompression raus. Aber zur Kompression gehören auch ganz andere Sachen. Also die offensichtliche Sache ist einfach, wie bewertet man, ob das komprimierte Signal noch die gleiche Qualität hat, wie das Ursprungssignal. Und das klingt zwar ganz einfach und da gibt es auch in der Signal-Technik wunderbare Verfahren, die benutzt werden, um zu sagen, ob jetzt eine Leitung wie Verlust hat. Und es gibt also Sachen, wie das Signal zu Rauschverhältnis. Und die greifen aber überhaupt nicht bei der Audiokompression, wie sie von MPEG benutzt wird, weil MPEG absichtlich Rauschen einfügt in das Signal, aber an Stellen, die nicht gehört werden. Also das ist überhaupt die Idee bei der verlustbehafteten Audiokompression, dass ich das Signal ungleichmäßig quantisiere. Also quantisieren ist der Übergang von einem analogen Signal in diskrete digitale Signale. Also das heißt, überhaupt alle Sachen, die von analog nach digital, das heißt in den Computer gebracht werden, werden quantisiert. Und die traditionelle Methode, die in Wavefile zum Beispiel benutzt wird, ist, dass ich pro Zeiteinheit n Samples nehme. Und das ist aber völlig überflüssig, weil das Ohr gewisse Eigenschaften hat, die man nutzen kann, um gewisse Samples gar nicht erst abzuspeichern oder sie mit weniger Bits zu repräsentieren, weil das dadurch induzierte Rauschen vom Ohr gar nicht wahrgenommen wird. Und um das mal anschaulich zu erläutern, wenn man in die Kirche geht und da sitzt der Organist an seiner Orgel und ist kurz davor, ein schönes Liedchen zu spielen, dann hört man das Gebläse der Orgel, aber wenn er dann loslegt, dann hat man das Gebläse eben nicht mehr, weil das von den anderen Signalen, die die Orgel von sich gibt, überdeckt wird. Und diese Maskierung gibt es auch bei anderen Geräuschen und auch bei Musik natürlich. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt eine Trommel unterlegte Musik habe, wie ja heute die Musik eigentlich meistens ist, dann ist während des Trommelimpulses der Gesang gar nicht zu hören oder nur ganz wenig. Das heißt, ich brauche viel weniger Bits, um den zu repräsentieren und so funktioniert im Grunde Impact.
Das ist ja leicht.
Das ist auch, wenn du zum Beispiel einen Orchester hast und da geht es tamtam, ein riesen Getöse und hinten im Hintergrund spielt irgendjemand noch Klavier, das hörst du gar nicht wirklich. Das ahnt man nur und das reicht auch da, eine unscharfe Ahnung von abzuspeichern. Das merkst du nicht mit. Übrigens vielleicht als Ausblick, das Ganze nennt man Psychoakustik. Da gibt es verschiedene Modelle, auch im MP3-Verfahren. Der Witz daran ist, der bringt mich immer durcheinander, der Witz daran ist, die arbeiten jetzt an neuen Psychoakustik-Modellen und der Ausblick geht dahin, dass man das noch massiv verbessern kann. Das, was das Ohr tatsächlich über den Hörnerv ans Gehirn überträgt, ist nämlich noch weit, weit, weit unter dem, was man heutzutage mit 128 Kilobit übertragen kann. Das ist so im wenigen Kilobit-Bereich das, was tatsächlich an Informationen durch den Hörnerv geht.
Na, man kann sogar noch besser komprimieren, wenn man sich überlegt, dass, wenn ich ein Klavierkonzert höre, ich im Grunde Tasten höre, die vorher bekannt sind. Das heißt, ich könnte, wie das ja MIDI zum Beispiel macht, wenn ich jetzt reine Orchestralmusik übertrage, einfach nur sagen, jetzt wurde Taste so und so gedrückt und vielleicht noch ein paar Parameter übertragen und dann habe ich ganz wenig Daten gebraucht, um mein Signal abzulegen. Also Kompression ist von vornherein klar gewesen, auch den MPEG-Leuten, dass das wunderbar möglich ist. Nur die Frage ist eben, wie bewertet man jetzt, ob ein Kompressionsverfahren zu viel Qualitätsverlust beinhaltet und die traditionellen Methoden greifen eben nicht und deswegen musste man ganz viel Geld ausgeben und die Studenten-Methode anwenden, auch die chinesische Horden-Methode genannt. Man hat halt viele Leute hingesetzt und hat ihnen die verschiedenen Methoden vorgespielt und da müssen die eben sagen, ob das jetzt gut war oder nicht. Und deswegen hat MP3 ganz lange gebraucht, bis jetzt, so weit ist es jetzt.
Jetzt hab ich gerade eine Menge Informationen dazu bekommen, was das überhaupt ist, Kompression von Musik und wie das funktioniert. Nicht, dass wir sie irgendwie verständen hätten, ich zumindest nicht. Aber ansatzweise weiß ich ein bisschen mehr. Wer sich da tiefer rein knien will, der kann das sicher tun. Im Netz gibt es darüber massige Informationen, unter anderem natürlich beim Fraunhofer Institut und bei vielen anderen davon unabhängigen Stellen. Jetzt hab ich also Songs in dieser CD-Qualität auf meinem Rechner und ich kann die da auch hören, wo ich die noch hören kann, irgendwann mal, da werden wir vielleicht auch noch zukommen, denn da entwickelt die Industrie einiges. Was in der Zukunft kommt, ist ein Walkman für MP3-Sounds, oder nicht nur MP3, soweit ich weiß, können wir gleich nochmal nachfragen. Ein Gerät, das sieht aus wie ein Walkman, ist aber viel, viel leichter, weil eben keine Mechanik drin ist, sondern nur kleine Chipkarten und das Ding hänge ich an den Computer und kann da meine MP3-Sounds drauf spielen. Und am Telefon haben wir jetzt Erich Böhm von Pontys. Und Pontys ist, sag ich das richtig, der Vertrieb für dieses Gerät oder sind Sie auch Hersteller, Herr Böhm?
Nein, wir haben das Geld auch entwicklen und werden das auch herstellen. Das heißt, Firmen werden das für uns herstellen. Wir haben es entwicklen und vertreiben das auch.
Verstehe, das Ganze nennt sich dann M-Player und werde ich sagen, es ist ein Walkman für MP3-Files, dann ist das richtig, oder? Sind ja die meisten MP3-Files, die im Moment so im Internet unterwegs sind, sind doch eigentlich im weitesten Sinne Raubkopierte-Geschichten?
Gibt es auch, aber es gibt auch jede Menge illegale Musik im Internet, die man sich runterladen kann und darauf. Es gibt Independent Labels und auch einfach Musikstücke, die man kaufen kann zum Teil oder zahl auch und sonst. Also es ist nicht nur illegal.
Was ist denn da für ein Speicher drin in diesem Player? Wie kommt sie überhaupt dahin vom Computer und wie wird sie dann da abgespeichert?
Wir haben ja die Multimedia-Card als Datenträger. Da gibt es also Flash-Karten und die Files werden über serielle Schnittstelle an den Player übertragen und dort auf den Karten abgelegt. Man kann aber auch die Karten direkt mit einem speziellen Interface vom PC aus bespielen ohne den Player. Die Multimedia-Card ist also ein genereller Datenträger für mobile Anwendungen wie Laptops und so was. Wird nicht nur für Musik eingesetzt, aber halt auch speziell für Musik.
Was kostet nicht so eine Karte im Moment?
Die Karten sind noch relativ teuer. Das kostet also für eine Viertelstunde Musik, knappe 100 Mark, weil es halt Flash-Speicher ist, also Halbleiter-Speicher. Es wird aber sehr schnell gehen auf das Bildergewirr. Die Kapazitäten werden sich verdoppeln und das Vierfach untergleich. Der Preis wird gleich bleiben, beziehungsweise eher sinken, das wird schon nächstes Jahr passieren.
Dann fragt sie natürlich nur, wann gibt es das Gerät, was wird das kosten und wo kriege ich mehr Informationen?
Das Gerät wird es ab Ende November geben. Karten kann man es bei uns über das Internet, über employer3.com. Wir haben ein Einführungspaket des Abspielgerätes mit Karten und mit einer limitierten Auflage von einer vorbestellten Karte für 429.
Ei, das ist nicht wenig, ne? Was kostet das Gerät dann später ohne Karten?
280.
Wie sehen Sie denn die Entwicklung? Man stellt ja so ein Gerät nicht her, aber man denkt, davon verkauft man ein paar 100 Stück. Haben Sie da mehr Informationen als wir vielleicht? Gibt es bei Ihnen Gespräche mit der Industrie, mit der Musikindustrie, was da in Zukunft auf uns zukommt an MP3 Sounds von offiziellen Stellen?
Also die Musikindustrie hält sich noch relativ bedeckt, aber natürlich denkt jeder drüber nach, die könnte es ja nicht einfach ignorieren. Ich glaube, dass es hier andersherum kommt, die Anwender werden das bestimmen und wollen das einfach und die machen das. Das sieht man jetzt schon an der Anzahl der MP3 Sites und der Download wird schon gemacht werden. Man kann das nicht nur ignorieren, das kommt einfach.
Gut, Erich Böhmer war das von Pontis und auf den Seiten www.mplayer3.com, so ist es richtig gesagt, ne? Da kriegt ihr mehr Informationen zu diesem MP3 Walkman. Hier gibt es noch Fragen.
Hallo, hier ist das Chaosradio, wir wollen uns mal ein bisschen einklemmen, dass es hier nicht irgendwie aussieht, als würden wir hier eine Werbeveranstaltung machen für irgendwelche Produkte. Wir sind ja auch nicht der einzige Anbieter. Wie schätzen Sie denn so andere Technologien ein, die jetzt zum Beispiel von der Telekom gepusht werden, mit Music-On-Demand-System, wo dann irgendwelche verkruppelten MP3-Formate verwendet werden?
Also ich glaube, dass es wichtig ist, dass man eine Art Wasserzeichen einfügt, die mit Musik umher- und rausfindet, wo die Musik herkommt. Also wirklich nur legale Musik vertrieben wird. Das Konzept von der Telekom ist meiner Ansicht zu respektiv. Ich glaube nicht, dass es die Anwender akzeptieren, die nicht nur mit meinem Passwort die Musik anhören können. Aber gemacht werden wird da was, dass man so ein Wasserzeichen zum Beispiel hat.
Haben Sie da schon was in der Entwicklung?
Da gibt es verschiedene Entwicklungen, was nicht wir machen, aber es gibt da Gremien, wo was gemacht wird. Also das Fraunhofer-Institut, Liquid-Audio oder auch Audio-Explosionen haben da verschiedene Sachen entwickelt. Das sollte zeigen, welche Standards sich dann durchsetzen.
Gut, das braucht Ihnen aber, das ist Ihnen wahrscheinlich relativ egal, oder? Ich meine, Sie bieten eine Hardware an, die nachher zum Mitnehmen dieser Soundfiles gemacht wird?
Nee, egal ist uns das nicht. A ist die Akzeptanz durch die großen Musikcomputer größer, sobald sowas standardisiert ist. Und die wissen wir natürlich die rechten Leistungen und das Einbauen, das Dekodieren, das Kopierschutz oder das Wasserzeigen. Das muss irgendwie mit integriert werden in das Berät.
Also wenn ich mal so plump fragen darf, warum interessiert uns das denn, ob die Musikunternehmen da Interesse dran haben? Also ich sehe das so im Walkman, da interessiert mich eigentlich auch nicht, ob da jetzt Virgin Interesse dran hat, ob das Ding da ist oder nicht. Wenn das auf dem Markt ist, dann ist das eben auf dem Markt. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die Musikunternehmen jetzt irgendwie ein Medium pushen oder nicht. Weil die Musik ist halt da, kann oft das Ding überspielt werden. Also welche Rolle spielt das für den Hersteller überhaupt, ob die Musikunternehmen da Interesse dran haben?
Weil wenn sie da kein Interesse dran haben, ist die Musik auch irgendwann nicht mehr da.
Punkt. Ich meine, es geht doch jetzt erstmal um den Anfang des Marktes. Also wenn ich jetzt so ein Gerät auf dem Markt tue...
Na gut, da können wir nachher wieder in die Tiefe gehen.
Ich verstehe deine Herangehensweise da überhaupt nicht. Aber okay, lass uns nachher nochmal drüber gehen. Entschuldigung, dass wir uns da jetzt kurz eingenutscht haben.
Eine Frage habe ich noch. Tim hat es vorhin angesprochen, Konkurrenzprodukte. MP3-Mann ganz vorne weg kommt jetzt auch dieses Jahr noch vor Weihnachten. Hat man mir versprochen, 64 MB RAM im System. Ich spiele das auf. Ratzenfatz, wie schätzen Sie das ein jetzt im Vergleich zu Ihrem Produkt? Nur mal wegen der Ausgewogenheit. Von wem kommt der? Wie heißt die Firma? MP3-Mann glaube ich heißt sogar die Firma. Ist irgendeine koreanische Produktion, wird momentan schon in den nordischen Ländern vertrieben, kommt jetzt Ende des Jahres in Deutschland auf Markt. Ist etwas teurer, hat aber dafür mehr als doppelt so viele Speicherkapazitäten.
Das Problem bei den anderen Produkten ist, dass sie den Speicher intern haben. Sie können den nicht wechseln. Was einmal draufgespielt worden ist, das ist drauf und man muss etwas wieder löschen. Wenn die Speicherpreise zwingen, können sie trotzdem nicht erweitern. Bei uns ist das besser kompatibel, als auch wenn es mal Karten gibt, die pro Karte 64 Metern Arbeit haben. Spielt sich mit demselben Gerät ab, hat zwei Slots und kann am beliebt wechseln. Also kann zwei, drei Stunden Musik davon.
Und auf diesen Karten haben Sie ganz normal das DOS Fallsystem drauf, oder wie?
Nee, ist auch möglich, aber wir haben jetzt ein spezielles Format, weil das DOS Fallsystem zu viel Overhead hat.
Und wie beschreibe ich ein spezielles Format in meinem Computer?
Es gibt Software dazu, wir liefern Software mit aus, mit der Sie dann die Daten herunterladen auf das Gerät.
Aha, und das läuft doch bestimmt nur wieder unter Windows?
Noch läuft es unter Windows, wir planen aber auch Linux und Next-Software.
Und geben Sie den Source-Code frei?
Haben wir heute darüber diskutiert, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Aha, das können wir ja nur unterstützen. Würden Sie sich auch nur ins eigene Bein schneiden, wenn Sie es nicht mehr haben?
Danke schön. Das war Erich Böhm von Pontus. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass Sie so lange wachgeblieben sind.
Ja, ich bedanke mich.
Ich bin immer mit Felix in die Haare, sorry Felix.
Und ich finde wir sollten das echt live diskutieren.
Ich war mal Künstler, ich war mal produzierender Künstler.
Ich will dir doch heute noch immer nur Künstler.
Okay, wenn du nicht meine ganzen Songs kopiert hättest, wär ich heute noch Künstler.
Ich hab hier noch ne Plan B-Artist.
Ich würde doch niemals Musik illegal kopieren, Johnny.
Nein, nein, ich hab ja jetzt den Finger nach draußen gezeigt.
In die Welt. Wenn ihr alle, wenn wir bessere gewesen wären, dann ist Johnny halb an den Rand jetzt.
Ich mach mal zusammen für die lieben Hörer.
Ihr da draußen, es geht darum, interessiert das jemanden, der so einen MP3-Player herstellt, ob Sony das gut findet oder nicht, beziehungsweise interessiert mich als der, der ich endlich ein Gerät habe, ohne mechanische Bauteile, wo ich meine Musik aufspiele, hab die in der Tasche, da kann ich toben machen, was ich will, die Musik kommt da raus, das kann ich ratzfatz von meiner Datemann bespielen, wie ich das will, das gibt es demnächst bestimmt auch als Autoradio und so weiter.
Und eine kleine Sache muss man vielleicht betonen, das Teil hat keine beweglichen Teile, das heißt da kann ich auch Bergwandern gehen, oder Auto fahren oder sonst wie Rucka Rucka.
Ganz genau, und das braucht auch nicht viel Strom, also da ist kein Motor drin, das hält ewig, das ist eine ganz prima Sache. Und es ist ein CD-Spieler ohne CD, so ein ohne bewegliches Teil, das ist eigentlich prima, es ist ein Medium, das dazu da ist, Musik abzuspielen. Und die Frage ist jetzt, die wir hier ganz heiß diskutieren, interessiert das eine Firma, die sowas rausbringt, ob Sony oder wen auch immer das gut finden, interessiert die Musiker das, finden die das toll oder nicht?
Und weitergehend, wenn Sony das nicht gut findet, könnten die überhaupt irgendwas tun, um zu verhindern, dass jemand MP3 mal auf den Markt baut? Oder wie man das Teil heißt?
Nö, das kann man natürlich nicht.
Nee, aber ich finde auch eine ganz andere Frage interessant. Sony produziert ja jetzt die Musik. Also letzten Endes tun das die Künstler, aber Sony vermarktet das in einer gewissen Art und Weise, bietet ihnen dafür dann auch gute Möglichkeiten, das zu tun. Aber von den 100% Musik, die sie produzieren, werden vielleicht drei bis fünf wirklich gepusht. So, die restlichen 95% floppen. Und deswegen ist dieser Kram auch relativ teuer, obwohl die Produktion so einer Musik, so einer CD, irgendwas um die acht Mark kostet, ist vergleichsweise billig. Zu dem, was man am Ende hinterher für bezahlen muss, das sind natürlich die Gewinnspannen, die Werbung usw.
Die Herstellung kostet eine Mark, ungefähr.
Ja, ich meine jetzt inklusive Tantiemen und Werbung an die Radiosender usw. Ungefähr acht Mark kosten, tut sie 35. Da sieht man mal, wo die Gewinnspanne wirklich hingeht.
Da sehe ich halt auch die Riesenchance im Netz. Deswegen glaube ich ja, dass das im Endeffekt wieder den Künstlern zugutekommen kann. Denn ich kann natürlich eine Menge Stationen dazwischen, die mitverdienen, ausschalten.
Genau, und da wollte ich den Bogen spannen. Und es geht nämlich hin zu einer Vielfalt, was wir momentan sowieso sehen. Es kommt alle Nasen lang was Neues raus, das durchaus auch gut ist. Nur die Majors schaffen das gar nicht mehr, von ihrer Kapazität diese Qualität auch wirklich zu pushen und da die Sachen rauszufinden, um sie dann zu promoten, weil das einfach viel zu schnell geht. Diese Kolosse wie Sony, Bertelsmann, Arreola, wie sie heißen, die sind einfach schon viel zu schwerfällig, um da überhaupt noch mitzukommen. Insofern habe ich so ein bisschen den Verdacht werden, die tatsächlich ein ziemliches Problem bekommen und relativ überrollt werden, wenn sich jetzt kleine Companies, gute Studios hinstellen und das kommerziell wie ein Provider anbieten. So, hier könnt ihr Musik hinstellen. Die schließen sich womöglich noch in einem Shareware-Freeware-Konzept zusammen, sowie CDDB, eine Datenbank, wo alle CD-Titel irgendwie du frei reinspielen kannst, jetzt nur die Titel und Interpreten, nicht die Musik. Aber du legst deine CD ein und schon sagt er dir im Computer, hat er die beschriftet, so in deiner Datenbank. Das ist eine ganz prima Sache, www.cddb.com.
Bolo ist gerade verkauft.
Ist jetzt nicht mehr frei.
Na gut, aber kann man sofort wieder selber frei machen, ist überhaupt kein Thema.
So funktioniert das heutzutage. Man gründet Firmen, damit man sie drei Jahre später verkauft.
Ja, natürlich, aber das war keine Turngründung, das war ein Privatmensch und kein Musikstudent.
Genau, jetzt stellen wir uns vor, diese ganzen kleinen Anbieter von Musik, die schließen sich zusammen in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Und dann haben wir ein Shareware, ein Freeware-Konzept, wo du alles an Musik findest, was dich interessiert. Also so ein paar Mainstream-Sachen, die findest du da nicht, weil die sind teuer. Aber die müssen sich dann auch was überlegen. Dann haben wir eine Independent-Kultur, eine Underground-Kultur, die wirklich so wie das Linux-Konzept, so richtig an den Majors kratzt. Und da haben sie Angst vor. Und deswegen gibt es ein paar Maßen, über die wir gleich auch noch sprechen wollen.
Du hast gesagt, Freeware, Shareware, sind denn diese Konzepte auf Musik anwendbar? Also Freeware ist ja noch extrem schwierig. Es gibt bestimmt Künstler, die sagen, ich mache hier Musik als Hobby. Und deswegen könnte das alle haben. Das ist ja auch cool. Und wir haben vorhin ja auch schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen. Eine kleine Band freut sich, wenn ihr Song 300.000 Mal kopiert wird, weil dann kennen sie einfach tierisch viele Leute. Eine große Band freut sich darüber nicht, weil ansonsten hätten die Leute das wahrscheinlich gekauft.
Da muss man gleich mal was dagegen sagen. Ich habe hier zwei CDs mitgebracht, die ich mir nur gekauft habe, weil ich die als M-Pack vorher gehört habe und ich habe die versucht, im Laden in Deutschland zu kaufen. Die gab es einfach nicht. Und das ist ein Markt, den man gar nicht unterschätzen sollte, wenn sich jemand für Britpop interessiert. Dann findet er in Berlin vielleicht irgendwo in Kreuzberg einen kleinen Laden, wenn er Glück hat. Aber wenn er jetzt auf dem Dorf wohnt, hat er verloren. Und solche Leute kann man bedienen über Internet und die haben überhaupt kein Problem, damit der Geld auszugeben. Und diese CD ist jetzt eine Frau aus Kanada, die habe ich dann aus Amerika bestellen müssen und habe ich überhaupt kein Problem, da Geld für auszugeben. Und es ist sogar so, dass ich mein CD, wo Kaufvolumen deutlich vergrößert hat, seit ich MP3 habe, weil ich mir das jetzt in Ruhe von zu Hause anhören kann, wenn ich Zeit habe. Und ich muss da nicht irgendwo mich anstellen bei Pro-Markt, wo halt irgendwie für 100 Leute, die da gerne mal reinhören wollen, so 5 CD-Player sind. Also diesen Stress habe ich nicht. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass den Leuten wirklich fast verloren geht. Ich finde Software und Musik ist wirklich sehr gutes Analogen, weil in beiden Fällen haben wir einen Producer, der Geld dafür ausgibt, dass er Software produziert, kostet Zeit und man muss auch Geld investiert haben für Bücher, man muss sich fortbilden, man hat viel Zeit seines Lebens damit verbracht, Programmieren zu lernen und Musiker müssen halt lernen, wie man Gitarre spielt oder Tavier oder singt oder keine Ahnung. Auch eine Ausbildung kostet genauso Geld, eine Produktion kostet Geld und während der Programmierer jetzt einen Computer braucht, braucht der Musiker eben Studio. Also das ist schon sehr vergleichbar. Und ich glaube nicht, dass die Musiker sich das jetzt leisten können, einfach dass sie die Software frei auf den Markt hauen, ihre gesamte Musik eben frei machen. Aber das ist ja auch bei Programmierern nicht so, dass die ihr Leben lang Freeware machen. Aber man macht halt so am Anfang ein paar Sachen als freie Software und macht sich Namen damit und lernt dabei. Und später hat man dann Namen und dann kaufen die Leute.
Warum muss dann die, also bei Shareware ist es ja zum Beispiel so, dass die dann, weiß ich nicht, entweder crippled ist oder safe disabled oder so ne Geschichten, wie stellt sie das dann bei Musik vor?
Na bei Musik gibt es ja einfach nur in schlechter Qualität als Freie Version.
Also die gibt es nicht in schlechter, sondern in nicht ganz so unter Qualität. Das ist dann aber wirklich crippleware. Shareware im einlichen Sinne ist ein Vertriebsmodell, was auf Freiwilligkeit basiert. Das heißt, wenn jemand einen konkreten Nutzen von dem erworbenen oder runtergeladenen Gut für sich sieht, dann bezahlt er freiwillig dafür Geld. Und zwar im besten Fall die Summe, die der Autor dieses Gutes genannt hat.
Was natürlich auch im Shareware-Bereich definitiv nicht wirklich funktioniert.
Na das funktioniert in Deutschland nicht besonders gut, aber das funktioniert in Amerika eigentlich hervorragend. Da ist die Community eine ganz andere Geschichte. Und wahrscheinlich auch letzten Endes daran, dass die Telekom irgendwie so teure Preise macht. Das funktioniert nicht zu weit, spannend. Aber ich bin durchaus der Mann, um das das Modell hinhauen kann. Und auch mit Crippleware wäre es möglich.
Weißt du, warum ich amerikanische Shareware ganz oft nicht bezahle? Weil ich mehr für die Überweisung bezahle, als für das Produkt. Ich sehe doch nicht ein, irgendeiner Beiziegel 15, 20...
Das ist aber seit ein, zwei Jahren kein Problem.
Also ich mache es deshalb nicht, weil ich den...
Ja, als Kreditkarte lehne ich ab, sorry. Habe ich keinen Bock auf.
Nein, aber ich will mal sagen, ich habe ungefähr doppelt so viel Geld für Shareware gezahlt, wie für richtige Software, die ich im Laden kaufe, weil die können ich dahin gehen und sage, ne, also das war doch nicht so treu, wie ich mir das gedacht habe. Dann sagt der Laden, ja, wissen Sie, das tut uns leid, Sie haben das gekauft, Sie haben das jetzt.
Wobei das natürlich so ein Ding ist, was bei mir so, ja gut, bei Musik gilt es eigentlich auch. Hätte mal kurz vorherhören, dann gefällt es mir und dann bezahle ich dafür. Das ist eigentlich angemessen.
Gut, da reden wir ja aber dann auch nicht von MP3 Qualität.
Nein, MP3 heißt nicht, dass die Qualität toll ist. MP3 ist genauso skalber wie die anderen MP3-Standards. Also man kann, MP3, das ist sogar deutlich weniger Platzbedarf, wenn ich die Qualität runterschraube, das heißt, das wäre noch ein weiterer Anreiz, sich die Sachen zu holen. Weil das dann einfach nur halb so groß ist. Oder man gibt es nur im Mono raus, dann ist nochmal die Hälfte des Platzes gespart.
Okay, wir vertiefen uns gleich noch ein bisschen diese Diskussion, wie man da mit Musik umgehen kann in Zukunft, oder wie man damit umgehen wird. Und wir haben ja auch zwei Leute hier, die es schon tun. Aber erstmal wollten wir noch mit Frauenhoferinstitut reden.
Ja, wir müssen über die Lizenzen noch was sagen vorher, oder? Warum wir denn überhaupt anrufen?
Genau, wollen wir noch ein bisschen Musik und diskutieren wir darüber.
Ja, aber ich muss den anrufen. Wollt ihr nicht kurz was zu den Lizenzen sagen?
Ja, ganz kurz. Also das Problem ist, dass MP3, also MP3 wird oft gesagt, das ist aber eigentlich nicht richtig, das ist Layer 3 bei MPK 1 und 2. Und das ist entwickelt worden im Rahmen eines EU-Projektes. Und da waren natürlich Firmen beteiligt, wie das so oft ist bei EU-Projekten. Und unter anderem war eben Fraunhofer Institut für integrierte Schaltung beteiligt. Und die haben da auch viel Aufwand reingetan und haben da eben Leute bezahlt, die sich das angehört haben und haben diese Modelle entwickelt. Und stellt niemand in Frage, dass die großartig da gearbeitet haben. Aber wie das auch so oft ist bei EU-Standards, das Patent für das Verfahren liegt am Ende bei dem, der es entwickelt hat, obwohl er das nicht bezahlt hat, sondern das EU-Gelder waren. Und in diesem Fall ist es eben so, dass Fraunhofer Institut und Thompson, SGS Thompson, die haben eben da mitgearbeitet und haben wichtige Teile von dem Layer-3-Algorithmus und von den Verfahren einfach patentieren lassen. Und das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mir selbst den ISO-Standard hole, was im Übrigen auch schon eine Frechheit ist, dass das Geld kostet, aber wenn ich mir das nach Hause kommen lasse und die 100 Dollar abgedrückt habe, dann habe ich da ein Buch, da steht drin, so macht man das. Und das ist ein internationaler Standard. Und ich setze mich hin mit meiner eigenen Zeit, mein eigenes Geld, mein eigenes Wissen, mein eigener Computer oder schreibe so ein Encode-Programm, was von Tape aufgenommene Sachen nach MPEG tut. Dann muss ich am Ende Lizenzgebühren an Fraunhofer abdrücken. Das heißt, diese Situation ist einfach da. Das kann man auch gar nicht Fraunhofer angreifen so direkt, weil die Situation ist bei ISO-Standards einfach generell so. Das System ist einfach verloren an der Stelle. Firmen wie Philips sind im Grunde schon längst Pleitekandidaten. Sie verdienen aber Geld, ohne da jetzt weiter was für zu leisten, weil sie halt mit EU-Geldern Projekte gemacht haben. Videokompression war Philips sehr groß. Und da leben die Firmen dann jahrelang von, dass sie eben Lizenzgebühren für Patente kassieren, wo im Grunde der Steuerzahler, also unter anderem viele in dem Raum hierfür bezahlt haben. Und das ist einfach ein System, da muss man sich überlegen, will man das oder nicht? Und wir wollen das eigentlich nicht haben.
Also so auf der Name Fraunhofer Institut gefallen, dass wir jetzt auch zumindest mit einem Menschen vom Fraunhofer Institut telefonieren, nämlich mit Herrn Gerhäuser, der ist, hoffentlich sage ich es richtig, Institutsleiter beim Fraunhofer Institut für integrierte Scheitungen, Abteilung MPEG. Ist das richtig, Herr Gerhäuser?
Abend.
Insgesamt mit vier Leuten haben sie es hier zu tun, ich wollte nur vorwarnen.
Genau, wir haben ein paar Fragen. Und zwar gab es vor nicht allzu langer Zeit, ob der Lizenzbestimmungen, die das Fraunhofer Institut für den MP3-Encoder und auch im professionellen Bereich für den Decoder herausgegeben hat, eine Abmahnung von einer Website, das war... Acht Herz. Und dort sollte also der MP3-Encoder, der dort von Studenten selbst auf Basis des Fraunhofer Verfahrens entwickelt worden war, verbessert worden war, vor allem was die Abarbeitungsgeschwindigkeit angeht, verbessert worden war, abgemahnt. Sie möchten für jede Version, die Sie kostenlos vertreiben, 25 Dollar an das Fraunhofer Institut überweisen. Und dazu wollten wir mal fragen, wie ist das jetzt wirklich mit den Lizenzbestimmungen zu den MP3-Encoder und auch dem Decoder? Was muss man dafür bezahlen? Warum muss man das bezahlen? Und wie hängt das alles mit zusammen?
Also Sie haben mir jetzt Fragen gestellt, wo wir wahrscheinlich längere Zeit darüber reden können. Ich habe aus dem Grund und zu meiner Vorbereitung auch noch mal ein bisschen ins Web reingeschaut und empfehle allen, die sich ein bisschen ausführlicher mit dem Thema befassen wollen, unter www.mp3.com nachzuschauen. Da gibt es zum Beispiel einen interessanten Beitrag, der sich nennt das Open Standard Mean Free. Und da kriegt man schon ein paar ganz interessante Hinweise, wie zum Beispiel die Standardisierung funktioniert und wie Schutzrechte, die in diesem Zusammenhang existieren, behandelt werden müssen. Und ich glaube, das ist ziemlich wichtig zu verstehen, dass Dinge, die patentiert sind, sozusagen bestimmten Rechten unterliegen. Man nennt das Schutzrechte. Und für diese Schutzrechte kann der Inhaber dieser Rechte Lizenzen verlangen. Insofern auch das Fraunhofer-Institut oder besser gesagt die Fraunhofer-Gesellschaft, die zusammen mit anderen Partnern Schutzrechte zu diesem Verfahren hat.
Wie hat denn das Fraunhofer-Institut eigentlich, ich fahr jetzt mal einfach doof dazwischen als Moderator, wie hat denn das Fraunhofer-Institut die Entwicklung überhaupt finanziert von diesen Verfahren?
Da darf ich vielleicht auch ein bisschen ausholen, weil das nämlich, glaub ich, auch nicht so bekannt ist.
Wir haben Zeit.
Fraunhofer-Institute werden nicht wie zum Beispiel Universitäten mit öffentlichen Mitteln subventioniert, oder besser gesagt nicht zu einem hohen Grad. Vielleicht darf ich mit dem Institut für integrierte Schaltungen hier in Erlangen etwas konkretisieren. Unser Institut erhält eine staatliche Grundfinanzierung von 15 Prozent, die übrigen 85 Prozent müssen wir uns über Auftragsforschung und Auftragsentwicklung verdienen. Unsere Kunden sind in diesem Zusammenhang Industriefirmen oder auch die öffentliche Hand im Rahmen von sogenannten öffentlichen Projekten, die ausgeschrieben werden und wo man sich im Wettbewerb mit anderen dann um diese Projekte bewerben kann. Also jetzt konkret, wie wurde das Audiokodierverfahren entwickelt? Und da darf ich vielleicht die interessierten Hörer mit dem Zeitraum ein bisschen vertraut machen. An dieser Audio-Technik wird am Fraunhofer-Institut seit 1985 gearbeitet, bis zum heutigen Tage. Und es wird sicherlich auch noch weit in die Zukunft gehen. Und vor diesem Zeitpunkt gab es bereits Entwicklungen oder Vorläuferentwicklungen, die damals noch an der Universität gemacht wurden. Aber so richtig, dass man es dann auch wirklich in eine konkrete Anwendung in Produkte übernehmen kann, das stammt also aus den Jahren 1985 oder kurz vorher. So wie wurde das jetzt finanziert? Da muss man verschiedene Phasen unterscheiden. Es gab also Phasen, wo wir das im Rahmen eines Industrieprojekts gemacht haben. Dann gab es Phasen, wo öffentliche Projekte beteiligt waren. Und es gab Phasen, wo wir diese 15% Grundfinanzierung einsetzen mussten, weil es nämlich weder das Industrieprojekt, noch das öffentliche Projekt gab, um diese Dinge voranzutreiben.
Haben Sie den Eindruck, dass sich da deswegen auch eine Menge tut und inzwischen ganz andere Leute Interesse an diesem Verfahren haben, weil Geschichten wie Musik im Netz und Music on Demand und so erst jetzt wirklich interessant werden, also für den Durchschnitts-User? Also haben Sie den Eindruck, dass plötzlich mehr Interesse an Ihrem Verfahren entstanden ist?
Also wir beobachten das Interesse an dem Layer 3. Das ist ja das so heiße Verfahren hier bei uns seit etwa zwei Jahren mit einer deutlich zunehmenden Tendenz. Das Ganze hat ganz lustig angefangen, wie damals die Standardisierung von Audio unter ISO vorangetrieben wurde. Gab es ja in der Anfangszeiten ein Verfahren aus unserem Haus, das nannte sich damals ASPEC. Ein Verfahren, was auch AT&T und Thomson mit einbezogen hat in die Entwicklung. Dieses Verfahren wurde aber, obwohl es die beste Audioqualität lieferte, deshalb zunächst abgelehnt, weil es angeblich die größte Komplexität im Verfahren, sprich die meisten Operationen pro Zeiteinheit und den größten Bedarf von Speichern erforderte. Es gab dann eine Phase, wo man Kompromisse geschlossen hat und die bereits akzeptierten Verfahren Layer 1 und Layer 2 durch den sogenannten Layer 3 ergänzt hat. Dadurch ist dieses Verfahren damals aus Sicht anderer als ein Verfahren für niedre Bitraten und damit natürlich auch eher für Low Quality betrachtet worden. Dass sich das dann innerhalb kurzer Zeit bei moderaten Bitraten zum Verfahren mit relativ hoher Qualität noch weiterentwickelt hat, das war zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt gar nicht so klar.
Eine Frage habe ich aber doch noch so ein bisschen zum Stil. Ich empfinde es also ähnlich wie große Teile aus der Net-Community, nenne ich das mal als schon eine gewisse Frechheit, einen Standard auf den Markt zu bringen, kann man schon so sagen, der gut und hilfreich ist, der vieles ermöglicht, was überhaupt ihr Institut gerade den Bereich IEC überhaupt erst bekannt gemacht hat, durch die Publizität dadurch, dass viele clevere Programmierer sehr gute Player geschrieben haben, die letzten Endes auf ihrer Kernimplementierung beruhen und so fort. Aber dass sie letzten Endes sehr stark profitieren davon, dass das Verfahren gut ist, das wollen wir durchaus würdigen und honorieren, aber auch dadurch, dass es eben einen gewissen sehr freien Umgang die ganze Zeit bis heute zumindest gab, mit diesem Know-how umzugehen. Und genau auf diesen Punkt hauen sie jetzt, sag ich mal salopp, mit der Keule und sagen so, und jetzt wollen wir aber von allen Geld haben. Das erinnert mir so ein bisschen an diese Giftgeschichte damals, als endlich alle Gift benutzten, weil es toll und praktisch war, kam dann der Patentlider und sagte so, und jetzt müsst ihr alle bezahlen. Ich würde das in der heutigen Zeit eher als sehr rufschädigend ansehen. Und das passiert auch, viele Websites haben keine Links mehr auf Frauenrufe, die das vorher hatten, und sagen ganz konkret, da laufen komische Sachen, die sind nicht gut, das wollen wir nicht. So gehört sich das nicht. Es ist also schon eine Frage an sich des Anstands. Man darf es schon als eine merkwürdige Strategie oder als typisch Deutsch bezeichnen, so eine Software wirklich unter Lizenzrecht zu stellen. Ich denke, es gibt da bessere Modelle zu sagen, okay, Player und Encoder für den Privatmarkt. Da kann jeder mitmachen, was er will für den professionellen Reich. Sobald jemand Geld damit verdient, soll er dafür auch bezahlen.
Mit wem habe ich denn jetzt gesprochen? Wenn Sie vielleicht Ihren Namen dazu sagen. Sie sind Herr Steinhauser. Also, ich glaube, dass wir da jetzt wieder bei dem Kernthema sind. Wo sind Schutzrechte vorhanden und wie geht man damit um? Ich glaube, das Missverständnis ist, dass diese Dinge nach Ihrer Aussage erst relativ kürzlich bekannt geworden sind, dass diese Dinge geschützt und zu lizenzieren sind. Ich glaube, dass ist eben das Missverständnis. Diese Dinge sind zumindest bei unseren Industriekunden und soweit ich weiß auch über unsere Webseiten schon eigentlich seit sehr langer Zeit bekannt.
Das war Gift seiner Zeit auch, aber inzwischen dem Schützen eines Contents und dem Durchsetzen dieses Rechtes daran ist doch noch ein weiter Weg. Uns interessiert eigentlich der Sinneswandel. Das war ja nun die ganze Zeit tatsächlich nicht so, dass sie dieses Recht auch durchgesetzt haben und jetzt aber mehr oder minder plötzlich und mit doch ziemlicher Härte umgesetzt wird. Uns interessieren da so eigentlich ein bisschen die Backgrounds. Wie kommt das, dass das gerade jetzt der Fall ist?
Na ja, man muss vielleicht auch einräumen, dass in Koda jetzt erst kürzlich überhaupt was...
Das sieht man hier weiter immer, dass ihr nachmittags richtig dann auch ansprechen kann.
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich bin ja von Leitner. Also die Frage ist, für mich als unbedarften User stellt sich die Sache so dar, ich hoffe, Sie korrigieren mich da gleich, dass Sie im Grunde ein Verfahren entwickelt haben und dafür haben teilweise Industrie und teilweise der Steuerzahler gezahlt. Und jetzt haben Sie aber die Rechte daran und nicht der, der dafür gezahlt hat. Und ich als Privatanwender, das ist jetzt ein internationaler Standard, der von der ISO geschützt ist, dass dieser Standard, ich im Grunde Geld dafür zahlen muss, dass ich das benutze. Und ein Standard sollte doch eigentlich genau die entgegengesetzte Wirkung haben, nämlich dass mir Kosten gespart werden, dadurch dass ich mir das nicht selber ausdenken muss und dass sich alle Leute im Grunde einig sind und es nicht 100 Standards gibt für Audiokompression und die Leute nicht miteinander reden können. Also im Grunde ist meine Betrachtung so, dass der Standard als Ziel hat, mich als Privatkunden mir die Möglichkeit zu geben, dass ich gute Audiokompression benutzen kann. Und ich kann es ja in Büchern nachlesen, wie das funktioniert, oder mir den Standard kommen lassen. Aber ich würde es ja noch nachvollziehen, wenn jetzt, sagen wir, Thompson hat sie beauftragt und Thompson würde jetzt mich versuchen zu verklagen, weil die halt Geld für das Verfahren ausgegeben haben. Aber wenn Frau Onover mich jetzt verklagt und sie haben das gar nicht auf eigene Kosten entwickelt, so stellt sich das da für mich, dann kommt mir das doch sehr merkwürdig vor.
Also jetzt war in den letzten Aussagen eine ganze Reihe von Unstimmigkeiten. Zunächst mal, wofür wir bezahlt wurden, das war die Entwicklung des Algorithmus, wofür man niemanden von vornherein vertraglich vereinbart bezahlen kann, ist, ob dabei Schutzrechte entstehen, also sprich zum Beispiel Erfindungen gemacht werden. In den meisten Fällen ist es so, dass der Auftraggeber, ob das jetzt eine Industriefirma ist oder das BMBF zum Beispiel, da bekommen sie das Geld oder wir bekommen das Geld dafür, dass wir ein bestimmtes Projekt entsprechend der Vorgaben, entsprechend der Pflichtenhefte bearbeiten. Was damit nicht vorhersehbar ist, ist, ob es da Erfindungen gibt, die man dann, woraus dann Schutzrechte entstehen können. Insofern sind das immer zwei Dinge, die tatsächlich auch manche unserer Kunden immer wieder durcheinanderbringen und das vergessen, wobei wir das normalerweise bei unseren Verhandlungen aber erläutern und auch vorher, bevor wir diese Verträge abschließen, sagen. Also, was ist jetzt, wenn man entsprechende Erfindungen gemacht hat, die zum Patent angemeldet hat, durch dieses Verfahren durchgegangen ist? Diese Erfindung wird dann zum Patent, es wird ein Patent erteilt. Und was jetzt viele nicht wissen oder nicht überblicken ist, dass dieses Verfahren des Schützens natürlich auch mit Aufwendungen verbunden ist. Vielleicht ist es hilfreich in dem Zusammenhang mal zu sagen, wie viel Lizenzeinnahmen unser Institut hat und wie viel Ausgaben für das Aufrechterhalten der Patente.
Aber berücksichtigen Sie dabei, dass Sie womöglich erhebliche Verluste dadurch erleiden könnten, dass Sie da durch diese Aktion deutlich an Ansehen in dieser Netzgemeinde verlieren?
Also es wäre natürlich bedauerlich, wenn wir an Ansehen verlieren.
Das ist aber nun erstmal der Fall.
Sie haben sich jetzt ein bisschen auf Fraunhofer eingeschossen. Aber erstens mal sind an diesen MP3-Richten nicht nur die Fraunhofer-Patente, sondern das sind, wie Sie wahrscheinlich wissen, auch Thompson-Patente.
Aber die Frage ist einfach, wir sind froh, dass wir überhaupt einen haben.
Warum hat sich Fraunhofer an der Stelle gemeldet und nicht Thompson? Da gibt es einfach ein Agreement, dass die mehr professionellen Dinge, und da gehören eben Encoder dazu, die werden vom Fraunhofer-Institut verwaltet und auch lizenziert, während die Firma Thompson sich um das Konsumegeschäft bemüht. Also zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt eine integrierte Schaltung gemacht wird, mit der diese Files dekodiert werden, das ist ein Thema, wo wir uns als Fraunhofer-Institut nicht darum kümmern. Aber dort, wo es um professionelles Equipment geht, dort wo es um Encoder, die ja in der Regel auch nicht in so großer Stückzahl benutzt werden, geht, da haben wir sozusagen ein Abkommen, dass wir das dann selber machen dürfen.
Also es gibt ja, wollen wir den schwarzen Peter dann in Anführungsstrichen, Häusler hier übrigens jetzt wieder, der Moderator der Sendung am Mikrofon, wollen wir den jetzt irgendwie nicht jetzt nur auf Fraunhofer konzentrieren, sondern dass da die Beteiligten...
Nein, ich glaube, wir sollten den schwarzen Peter auf Neman konzentrieren, denn es handelt sich hier nicht um etwas ganz Ungewöhnliches, sondern das ist etwas, was bei allen Standards und bei allen anderen Prozessen, wo eben Lizenzen beteiligt sind, immer wieder das Gleiche ist.
Das ist ja auch klar.
Die große Masse in der Regel nicht weiß. Was sie wahrscheinlich nicht wissen, ist, dass auch bei DVB und bei diesen ganzen anderen Standards natürlich Lizenzen dabei sind. Der größte Teil der Patentinhaber hat gegenüber also eine Erklärung abgeben müssen, dass die Schutzrechte und die Skate sozusagen offengelegt werden und dass man für diese Schutzrechte nicht diskriminierende Lizenzen vergeben muss. Das heißt, dass man nicht jemanden, den man besonders gerne hat, der kriegt es billiger und einen, den man überhaupt nicht leiten kann oder den man als Konkurrenz aus dem Weg schaffen will, der muss besonders viel bezahlen. Und deshalb hat natürlich sozusagen im Gegenzug auch die Wirkung, dass wenn ein Industriekunde für einen Encoder eine Lizenz bezahlt, dann darf man natürlich nicht jemand anders diese Lizenz schenken. Sonst wäre das auch wieder diskriminierend.
Also Sie meinen, dass jetzt einige Newsern so vorkommen, als ob Fraunhofer und Thompson jetzt plötzlich ankommen. Das liegt eigentlich daran, dass sie es vorher nicht so richtig mitbekommen haben.
Also ich habe ein bisschen den Verdacht, dass die Betroffenen nicht sehr gründlich recherchiert haben. Also es wäre überhaupt kein Problem gewesen, das in unserem Haus zu erfahren, ein Anruf, ich glaube die Telefonnummer ist ja verfügbar, hätte das geklärt. Aber ich vermute eben, dass niemand diese Frage so konkret gestellt hat. Und jeder ist wohl davon ausgegangen, dass man Dinge, die eben standardisiert sind, auch selbstverständlich kostenlos haben kann. Aber das ist wirklich, das trifft nicht zu. Vielleicht einige Beispiele, wo man es noch erläutern kann. Wenn Sie heute zum Beispiel eine CD kaufen, dann erwerben Sie, ohne dass Sie das wissen, eine Lizenz. Nämlich die Lizenz, die Musik, die auf diesem Medium gespeichert ist, unter bestimmten Regeln zu verwenden. In diesen Regeln steht zum Beispiel drin, dass Sie das nur für Ihren eigenen Zweck und nur für bla bla bla verwenden dürfen und auf keinen Fall für irgendwelche anderen kommerziellen Dinge. Das ist auch etwas, wo keiner so richtig dran denkt, wenn er eine CD kauft. Mit dieser Musik kann ich jetzt alles machen, was ich will.
Ich darf eigentlich gar keine Partys größer machen damit.
Genau, weil das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, der immer wieder übersehen wird. Und der führt natürlich dann auch zu ganz merkwürdigen Auswüchsen. Ich vermute fast, dass Sie auf dieses Thema noch kommen werden. Das ist die Musikpiraterie.
Ja, wir haben es schon angesprochen natürlich und werden auch noch weiter darüber reden. Ich glaube, es gibt hier noch eine Abschlussfrage.
Letzte Frage von mir noch. Die Musikindustrie, von der auch schon die Rede war, spielt die in diesem Zusammenhang eine Rolle, dass Sie an der Ecke einmal doch recht hohe Lizenzgebühren verlangen und zum anderen die jetzt überhaupt durchsetzen oder gibt es da überhaupt keinen Zusammenhang?
Also auch wieder differenzieren. Sie sprechen von den sehr hohen Lizenzgebühren. Ich muss sagen, diese 25 Dollar, die da im Gespräch sind, das ist für Einzelstücke. In dem Augenblick, wo jemand viele Encoder aus irgendwelchen Gründen braucht, gibt es dann auch eine entsprechende Staffelung, sodass dann, ja, wenn jemand jetzt, sagen wir mal, eine Million Encoder brauchen wird, dann sind die Zahlen völlig anders. Aber jetzt die sehr viel spannendere Frage, hat dieses Zu-Wort-Melden, und da möchte ich doch nochmal darauf zurückkommen, warum hat sich das Farnhofer Institut erst jetzt gemeldet und nicht schon bei anderen Verstößen? Da ist noch Folgendes zu sagen. Es gibt eine Reihe von Encoder-Implementierungen, die sind so schlecht, dass wir immer der Meinung waren, es lohnt sich für die nicht, ein großes Theater zu machen. In solchen Fällen haben wir die betroffenen Lieferanten lediglich ermahnt, das sein zu lassen. Und wir gehen davon aus, dass es erst dort kritisch wird, wo Software zum Einsatz kommt, die praktisch unsere letzten Entwicklungsergebnisse auch enthält und damit diese sehr hohe Qualität sicherstellt.
Also ein klares Nein auf die Frage, ob sie von den großen Anbietern von Musik dazu aufgefordert wurden?
Das kann ich mit einem ganz klaren Nein bezeichnen, aber ich möchte gern die Verbindung zu der GEMA herstellen. Und da denke ich, ist es ganz wichtig zu hören, dass unserem Haus sehr daran gelegen ist, dass die Inhaber von Rechten an Musik auch wirklich zu ihrem Recht kommen.
Ich glaube, da haben wir nachher auch noch eine Menge zuzuhören und zu sagen.
Aber ich glaube, das sind die ersten Fragen damit einigermaßen beantwortet.
Ich glaube, das war ein sehr interessantes Gespräch und auch ein sehr ausführliches.
Dann darf ich Ihnen nochmal die Webseite von unserem Institut erzählen. Das ist www.iis.fhg.de.flash.amm.flash.legal.flash.index.html Sagen Sie mal, die hätten Sie aber auch ein bisschen einfacher machen können, oder? Also das ist jetzt der gesamte Pfad, ja. In dem Pfad rein, sodass Sie nicht lange suchen müssen, mit www.iis.fhg.de kommt man auf unsere Homepage und von dort aus kann man entsprechend verzweigen. Wir haben dort Frequently Asked Questions, wir haben Legal Matters und weitere interessante Informationen. Die ganze Geschichte wird dann noch mal ein Stück spannend, wenn es sozusagen um die nächste Generation geht. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie heute schon über AAC gesprochen haben. Also auch da wird genau das gleiche Problem auftreten. Viele Technologie-Anbieter halten es eigentlich nicht für so wichtig, auf diese Schutzrechte hinzuweisen. Wir tun es eigentlich immer relativ frühzeitig. Also natürlich erst dann, wenn die Patente erteilt sind. Man kann ja nie wissen, ob so ein Patent nicht auch mal abgeschossen wird.
Herr Geirhauser, ich muss Ihnen ein bisschen ins Wort fallen, weil Sie nehmen jetzt schon viel zu viel vorweg von dem, was wir in den nächsten anderthalb Stunden hier noch vor uns haben. Ich bedanke mich erstmal bei Ihnen sehr, sehr herzlich, dass Sie so lange wach geblieben sind und hier für uns live zur Verfügung standen und doch einiges Licht in die ganze Angelegenheit gebracht haben.
Werden Sie mich in dieser Sendung nochmal ansprechen? Nee.
Aber ich kann Ihnen gleich nochmal anständig Tschüss sagen. Aber der Regler kommt jetzt runter. Wir müssen nur kurz noch warten, weil wir haben gleich eine Info. Das war Herr Gahrhäuser, Institutsleiter beim Fraunhofer Institut für integrierte Schaltung Abteilung MPEG.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
So, 23.35 Uhr.
Terror bei dem Bombenanschlag im jüdischen Stadtteil Hebron. Von Hebron sind nach neuesten israelischen Angaben 23 Menschen verletzt worden. Zwölfte Opfer seien israelische Soldaten, 11 Palästinenser. Ein Unbekannter hatte zwei Handgranaten auf einen israelischen Armee-Jeep geschleudert. Reaktionen der Weltsicherheitsrat wird morgen zu einer Dringlichkeitssitzung über die Situation in der Krisenprovinz Kosovo zusammenkommen. Hintergrund sind jüngste Berichte über Gräueltaten an Albanern. Schulterschluss Deutschland und Frankreich wollen nach dem Machtwechsel in Bonn neuen Schwung in ihre Zusammenarbeit bringen. Bei seinem Antrittsbesuch in Paris vereinbarte der künftige Bundeskanzler Schröder mit Staatspräsident Shirak die Bildung von Arbeitsgruppen zur Europapolitik. Ergebnislos, das Gespräch zwischen dem britischen Premier Blair, dem nordirischen Protestantenführer Trimble und Shin-Fan Chef Adams über eine Entwaffnung der IRA hat heute keinen Durchbruch gebracht. Es wurden weitere Verhandlungen angekündigt. Fußball in der Champions League spielte Bayern München 2 zu 2 gegen Manchester United. Torlos 0 zu 0 ging das Spiel des 1. FC Kaiserslautern beim finnischen Meister Hjk Helsinki aus.
Wetter.
Heute Nacht aufkommender Regen bei 11 bis 8 Grad am Tage. Regnerisch Temperaturen 10 bis 13 Grad.
Verkehr.
Stadtautobahn Berlin, Tempelhof Wedding zwischen Kreuz Wilmersdorf und Kurfürstendamm Schwarzbacher Straße sind wegen einer Baustelle bis 5 Uhr in Richtung Nord die linke und mittlere Spur und in Richtung Süd die linke Spur gesperrt.
Ein Fritz-Kurz-Info mit Gerhard Katahimreich.
Einen wunderschönen guten Tag, hier ist König Boris von Fettes Brot und ich empfehle dringend am Samstag von 12 bis 17 Uhr Fritz zu hören. Ihr wisst ja, viele Wege führen nach Rom, aber am Samstag sind wir in Berlin und da wollen wir mit euch ein hochkomplexes Such-und-Find-Esspiel spielen, bei dem es uns zu finden und jede Menge zu gewinnen gibt. Also vormerken, Samstag, 12 bis 17 Uhr, Fettes Brot in Berlin und im Radio und das heißt wie immer Fritz.
Nicht so, dass die Sendung unstressig ist. Mit tausenden von Telefonaten, Interviews, gleich Live-Gäste. Seid ihr noch wach?
Ist ne Menge los heute.
Ja, aber ist ja schön, ist ja Chaos Radio. Man hört Chaos Radio jeden Mittwoch und Monat bei Fritz. Rund um Computerthemen mit dem Chaos Computer Club.
Ja, ich mein, jetzt sind wir schon wieder bei so einem sehr interessanten politischen Thema gelandet. So irgendwie haben wir einen schnellen Sprung gemacht jetzt von der Technik dahin, aber jetzt gerade diese Diskussion hier am Telefon, die hat halt irgendwie gezeigt, wo der Haken ist. Also wir leben jetzt irgendwie in einer Welt, in der halt die Erfindung irgendwie die Markt macht. Nicht die Jungs, hat er ja selber gesagt, die werden da irgendwie bezahlt von der Industrie, von der EU oder von wem auch immer, bezahlen das, also kriegen das bezahlt, entwickeln. Also für ihre eigentliche geistige Tätigkeit haben sie ja durchaus was bekommen. Und dann erfinden sie halt jetzt irgendwas, auf das sie ein Patent erheben. So ist das ja mit Patenten immer so eine Sache, so dass es irgendwie so was, so ich habe zuerst irgendwie geschneit, wie irgendetwas funktioniert. Und das ist jetzt ein Beitrag für die Weltgemeinschaft und deswegen muss ich auf Ewigkeiten dafür Geld bekommen. Jetzt sieht es so aus, dass dann so was wie MP3, was eben jetzt auf dieser Arbeit von Fraunhofer und Thompson und so weiter basiert, wird dann eben zum Standard erhoben und ist damit ja im Prinzip auch ein Zwang, dass man dieses System verwendet. Also ich meine Standard ist natürlich auch eine wünschenswerte Geschichte. Aber es ist in dem Moment, wo das Ding als Standard verankert ist, zwangsläufig ein Zwang, weil sich natürlich ganz automatisch die ganze Industrie darauf eben standardisiert.
Erklär doch mal bitte noch, was ich nicht so richtig verstehe. Heißt das, dass jeder, der...
Ich kann es mal vorlesen.
Also warte mal, implementieren heißt das, wenn ich die Song...
Implementieren heißt, ich, kleiner Programmierer, schreibe mir MP3-Encoder und dann muss ich an Fraunhofer abdrücken.
Moment, du schreibst einen Encoder, was ist, wenn ich deinen Encoder benutze, um einen Song...
Ich darf den dir gar nicht geben, den Encoder ohne an Fraunhofer abzudrücken.
Okay, du benutzt ja auch deren Standard dafür. Also jetzt mal kurz...
Moment, das ist auch noch so eine Sache, die nicht ganz unstrichig ist. Fraunhofer stellt das Ganze da, als wenn sie den komplett allein entwickelt haben oder zumindest 90, über 90 Prozent, aber das ist nicht so. Also das muss man einfach mal so sagen. Die haben da große Teile von gemacht, keine Frage, aber es ist ein internationaler Standard. Da haben Italiener, Amerikaner, Franzosen, Japaner mitgearbeitet, da waren viele Leute beteiligt. Und dass jetzt im Grunde Fraunhofer sich hinstellen kann und von allen Leuten Geld kassiert, das ist einfach...
Du weißt ja nicht, wie das intern verteilt wird.
Also das kann doch nicht...
Nein, nein, das ist ein Patent. Die haben das Patent da drauf und die kriegen die Kohle, weil sie als erstes dieses Patentrecht durchgesetzt haben.
Man darf vielleicht noch eine andere Sache erwähnen. MP3 ist ja noch gar nicht das Schlimmste, sondern es gab ja jetzt dieses Human Genom Projekt. Wo sie dann immer...
Das bitte nicht wieder abschweißen.
Nein, aber das ist einfach ein generelles Problem. Es gab eine Firma, die hat angekündigt, dass sie den menschlichen DNA-Bestand mappen möchten und dass sie haben am Ende angekündigt, aber sie werden da kein Patent darauf erheben. Aber wenn man sich überlegt, dass eine Firma ein Patent auf die Darstellung der menschlichen Gene haben kann, dann muss man einfach sagen, dieses System steht so, wie es ist.
Das musste wahrscheinlich bei der Erzeugung von neuen Menschen irgendwie durch den sexuellen Geschlechtsakt musste dann irgendwie auch noch Patent geben.
Ich warte auf den Tag, wo ein Wort patentiert wird und du für die Benutzung dieses Wortes Geld abdrückst.
Das kann passieren. Wir gehen wirklich in eine Zeit, in der es ja nicht mehr um wirkliche Waren geht, sondern Gedankengut ist jetzt die Ware.
Siehe Herr Steinhöfel, der irgendwie die Frechheit gehabt hat, irgendwie D-Kran-Technik irgendwie abzumahnen, weil die irgendwie D- verwendet haben. Dieser Steinhöfel ist sowieso noch mal jemand, der irgendwie noch mal eine schwere Zeit haben sollte, in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft.
Moment, was hat der? Erklär das mal kurz.
Herr Steinhöfel ist jemand, der diese D-Info-CD auf den Markt gebracht hat und damit erstmal irgendwie der Telekom irgendwie kräftig Schweiß auf die Stirn getrieben hat, weil er irgendwie eine Million Chinesen beschäftigt hat, Telefonbücher abzutippen und dann eben CDs rausgebracht. Von der die Telekom glaubte, sie könnte noch für zehn Jahre für teuer Geld verkaufen. Also ich meine, das sind ja auch irgendwie alles heiß am Schneider so, aber dann hat er sich also wunderbar da eingereiht und angefangen irgendwie zu behaupten, ja, es wäre ja eine großartige, zukunftsträchtige Idee, es alles irgendwie mit D- vorne zu benennen. Und dann hat er irgendwie angefangen, erstmal eine Firma zu verklagen, die im www.d-krantechnik.de beantragt hat. Also er folgt im Internetbereich. Das ging halt grundsätzlich über dieses Markenrecht. Er hat halt irgendwie gesagt, naja, alles, was mit D- anfängt, das ist irgendwie meins. Damit ist er dann tatsächlich ein paar Mal durchgekommen, was schon mal eine Frechheit für sich ist. Dann hat er das aber maßlos übertrieben, als er nämlich irgendwie das Deutschlandradio für D-Radio.de abklagen wollte. Und da ist dann irgendwie dem Richter dann auch der Kran geplatzt und dann hat er gesagt, du hast doch wohl eine Maise. Also in einer Weile dreht sich jetzt der Chaos ein bisschen rum, gibt es auch diese tolle Aktion Freedom4Links, die man auf www.ccde irgendwie auch verlinkt haben und die sich eben gegen solche Sachen durch sind. Aber genau das ist dieser Punkt. Da gibt es einfach Leute, die halt irgendwie geistig tun. Das tun wir ja auch. Man auch uns fällt irgendwie was ein. Es kann sogar sein, dass irgendein Freak, das tatsächlich vorher eingefallen ist, wie man psychoakustische Modelle machen kann. Es kann sogar sein, dass er irgendwie Kot gehabt hat. Nur Fraunhofer hat irgendwie auch noch eine ganze Batterie von Juristen, die dann irgendwie sofort beim Patentant anrufen und sagen, hier, wir sind die Coolsten, wir tragen das jetzt mal ein, wir haben das erfunden und so weiter. Und jetzt wird das eben Standard. Und auf einmal sind alle Leute gezwungen, denen Geld dafür zu bezahlen, nur weil denen das mal eingefallen ist. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die irgendwie Geld für irgendeine Leistung oder sowas bekommen oder dass sie noch irgendetwas tun. Der sprach davon hier gerade, der Kollege, dass er irgendwie unglaubliche Geld aufwenden müsste, um seine Lizenzen einzutreiben. Ich meine, wo leben wir denn? Ich meine, das ist ja genau der Punkt. Diese Lizenz darf nicht existieren, in dem Moment, wo das ein Standard ist.
Also das Schwierige an der ganzen Geschichte finde ich nicht so sehr, dass sie versuchen, da ein System zu lizenzieren, also in Lizenz treten zu lassen. Das finde ich noch nicht okay. Aber was ich halt schon sehr mag, will ich finden, ist, dass es erst jahrelang dulgen, damit es sich durchsetzt als Standard. Und wenn es sich dann durchgesetzt hat, wenn es also schon irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, so und so viele Millionen Files mit diesem Standard encodiert gibt, dann wird gesagt, ach so, übrigens, das habt ihr vielleicht alle nicht gelesen. Als Kleingedruckte. Und das ist schon eine etwas schräge Geschichte.
Ja, ganz so schlimm ist das doch nicht gewesen. Also es klingt, wir übertreiben das jetzt hier ein bisschen. Mal unser Fertig mal gerade rücken. Die arbeiten da zwar seit 1987 oder 85, hat er gesagt, dran, aber Layer-3-Implementationen gibt es seit knapp anderthalb Jahren. Da gab es die erste Software von Fraunhofer. Die waren halt auch die ersten mit der Software. Und das ist auch noch nicht so lange hier, dass die angefangen haben, Leute abzumahnen. Also das Patent ist auch noch nicht so lange auf deren Seite. Es ist nicht so, dass die gewartet haben. Aber es ist eben so, dass die zwei, drei Encoder haben durchgehen lassen. Und was ich aber, das finde ich nicht verwerflich. Ich meine, das ist ja ihre Sache, ob die ihr Geld eintreiben oder nicht. Aber dass das ein internationaler Standard ist und Leute von der ITU dazu aufgefordert werden, diesen Standard zu benutzen, indem die das sanktionieren. Das ist eine internationale angesehene Organisation. Die zwingen mich als kleinen Anwender, wenn ich auf dem Musikmarkt irgendwas tun will, dann muss ich MP3 benutzen, weil das ist Weltstandard. Und ich bin dann auch gleichzeitig gezwungen, Kohle abzudrücken und das macht mein Produkt teuer. Und die Einzigen, die das nicht abdrücken müssen, ist Fraunhofer selbst und das ist einfach ein Vorteil, den die nicht haben dürfen, sollten, meine Ansicht nach.
Musik und Platz schaffen, Mikros wechseln, einstellen.
Ist ja nicht so, dass wir hier weniger werden.
Die Frage, was soll ich jetzt tun, ist großartig, finde ich. Wir machen jetzt erstmal, wir mussten hier die Mikros ein bisschen umbauen. Wir sind jetzt zu fünft, mal gucken. Tim geht sowieso, ist klar. Geht ihr beide?
Ja, das geht auch.
Warte mal, noch ein bisschen lauter, mal noch mal.
Soll ich mal brüllen, dann ist hier richtig laut.
So, wunderbar. Nee, dichter ran. So, wunderbar. Jetzt sind nämlich noch zwei Leute mehr geworden. Jetzt klingt es auch ein bisschen mehr nach Raum hier alles. Zwei Saschas sind da, Sascha Zimbusch und Sascha Simbong. Beide von Moveabit. Was das genau ist, das können die beiden euch gleich am besten selber erklären. Dann jetzt kommen wir nämlich zu der auch kommerziellen Seite dieser ganzen Geschichten. Es gibt ja schon einige Anbieter, die mit dem Stichwort Music-On-Demand unterwegs sind. Da ist einmal die Telekom. Da können wir gleich auch noch ein paar Sätze zu sagen. Da gibt's oder gab's Fragezeichen eine Firma, die MCY heißt und da gibt es Moveabit. Was macht ihr mit Moveabit, was ist das?
Also Moveabit ist einer der ersten kommerziellen Audio-Vertriebe übers Netz. Wir fangen jetzt mit zwei Musik-Services an, die zum November dann offiziell starten werden. Das eine ist Trendpool. Trendpool ist ein Talent-Förderungsbereich für Unsigned-Bands, junge und bekannte Bands, die sich gegen eine Bearbeitungsgebühr auf diesen Seiten präsentieren können. Auf der anderen Seite versuchen wir, Kontakte A in die Musikindustrie zu kriegen, dann aber auch direkten Förderungsbereich offline zu erzeugen, durch Kooperationen mit Medienpartnern, mit Vereinenversicherungen, die schon in diesem Bereich Talentförderung tätig sind, Live-Auftritte und so weiter und so fort. Der andere Bereich ist BitPool. BitPool ist unser kommerzieller Schaltplatten-Shop oder Audio-Shop im Internet, wo man sich über eine Software Liquid Audio aus Amerika gegen Entgelt-Songs runterladen kann. Das ist so die grobe Beschreibung erstmal.
Das kommt nicht mal ungefähr, dass ihr da beide mit zu tun habt, denn du, Sascha, warst 10 Jahre bei EFA. Das heißt, EFA ist einer der größten und ältesten Indipendenvertriebe im Deutschland, kann man so sagen. Der andere Sascha ist gleichzeitig nicht nur von Movabit, sondern von TCPIP. Provider, Internetprovider, kann man so sagen. Chaos-Jungs, hören wir auch. Jetzt fangen wir einfach mal an direkt darüber zu reden. Bevor wir jetzt die Mitstreiter nochmal vorstellen, kommen wir bestimmt automatisch drauf. Aber kann man erstmal damit anfangen. Du hast gesagt, ein Entgelt. Also ihr beschafft so einen Pool für unbekannte Bands, beziehungsweise für ungesignte Bands, die auch keinen Plattenvertrag haben. Ziel soll irgendwann sein, dass über diesen Pool Kontakte zur Industrie entstehen. Also zum Beispiel sollen dann wahrscheinlich die A&A-Manager der Plattenfirmen da mal reinhören und sagen, ach guck mal, die klingen ja gar nicht so schlecht, weil sie längst den Überblick verloren haben. Entgelt heißt, wie viel kostet das eine Band da vertreten zu sein?
Also die Einpflegung kostet 150 Mark und dann kostet es 50 Mark monatlich. Das klingt vielleicht auch erstmal viel. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man bedenkt, was jetzt, wenn sich eine Band irgendwie versucht, bei Plattenfirmen zu bewerben, dann muss sie die Tapes herstellen, muss die wegschicken, muss telefonieren, muss auf jeden Fall möglichst auch die Leute kennen, die sie da überhaupt ansprechen. Also das heißt, wenn man das mal gemacht hat, weiß man, was das für ein Aufwand ist, sich irgendwie ein Tape mal an jemanden zu kriegen, der sich das dann auch wirklich anhört. Dazu muss man einfach auch sagen, die A&Rs werden mit Tapes und Demos zugeballert. Und wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel erste Kontakte auch gerade zu Musikverlagen geknüpft, die dieses Konzept sehr interessant finden, weil sie sagen, okay, dann kriege ich eine Mail, da sind fünf Links drin und da kann ich draufklicken und dann kann ich den Song gleich hören. Und dann kann ich sagen, okay, ist was oder kann ich nichts mit anfangen?
Aber die Telefonate hab ich doch trotzdem, oder? Oder macht ihr das auch für die Band?
Ich lass jetzt mal meinen Partner antworten.
Ja, ich bin schon ganz nervös. Es ist ja folgendes zu sehen, es handelt sich hier nicht um ein simples Web-Posting oder sowas, sondern das ist eigentlich nur die technische Repräsentanz der Geschichte. Das Encoding und das Einstellen ins Netz mit einer guten, vertretbaren Qualität, inklusive kostenlosen Download der Songs, ist erst der Anfang. Danach geht es daran, dass wir für die Bands eine Marktforschung machen. Das heißt, aufgrund der Statistiken, zum Beispiel das Verhältnis Strings zu Download und ähnlichen Geschichten, fahren wir eine Marktforschung, die die Bands in die Lage versetzt, zum Beispiel Tonträgerfirmen gegenüber besser zu argumentieren. Des Weiteren machen wir Promotions, indem wir zum Beispiel in Form von Werbeinseraten Charts publizieren, also die Top Ten im Trendpool zum Beispiel. Wir sind im Gespräch mit dem See Deutschen Rundfunk über eine eigene Sendung zu diesem Thema, wo also einmal im Monat Trendpool Bands vorgestellt werden sollen. Es sind erste Kontakte zu diversen Fernsehsendern geschaltet worden, wo man darüber nachdenkt, welche Bands vorzustellen, auf Basis unserer vorbereitenden Tätigkeit.
Habt ihr nicht Angst, dass die Leute sich das eine Weile ankommen und sagen, eigentlich eine geile Idee, dann lass uns doch selber uns zusammenschließen?
Ja, das kann natürlich passieren. Aber man muss ja sagen, der Trendpool Service ist ja nicht in erster Linie ein kommerzieller Service per se. Woran wir verdienen, das muss man ganz klar sagen, ist, dass wenn eine Band Erfolg versprechend ist, bieten wir dieser Band selber einen Vertrag an. Also wir sind nicht nur ein Web-Hoster oder Service-Betreiber, sondern wir sind auch eine Produktionsfirma, wir sind auch ein Musikverlag und so weiter. Wir betreiben auch unsere eigene Forschung.
Ach so?
Das sind ganz böse Kommerzielle.
Nein, ich finde überhaupt diese kommerziellen Gedanken ja nicht immer böse. Nur was unterschreibe ich denn für einen Vertrag bei euch, wenn ich sage, ich zahle die 150 Mark und 50 Mark im Monat, dass meine Band da vertreten ist?
Das kann man sich selber aussuchen. Also der erste Vertrag ist natürlich erstmal der Service-Vertrag über den Trendpool selber, dass man also einen bestimmten Service in Anspruch nimmt und dafür eine Gebühr bezahlt. Danach kann man sich selber aussuchen, was man mit uns machen möchte, also welchen Vertrag man schließen möchte, wenn man einen schließen möchte und wenn man ihn schließt, dann ist er zeitlich begrenzt und erfolgsabhängig. Das heißt, wenn nichts verkauft wird, wenn kein Geld fließt, dann ist dieser Vertrag aufgehoben. Also wir haben sehr viel recherchiert, auch in der Musikbranche und auch bei Bands und Musikern. Da haben sie nach ihren Bedürfnissen gefragt und haben versucht, also ein sehr faires Modell aufzusetzen, weil der Trendpool ist wirklich erst mal dazu da, die Musiker und die Musikindustrie zusammenzubringen. Ja, das ist erst mal die Hauptsache. Denn verdienen tun wir im kommerziellen Service, das ist der Bitpool-Bereich, wo wir also für Musikfirmen online Musik verkaufen und promoten. Das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Gut, gehen wir mal von diesem kommerziellen Bereich rein, zu Bitpool. Wie sind da bis jetzt die Reaktionen der Plattenfirmen? Die tun sich doch eigentlich sehr schwer damit, oder?
Also in dem ganzen MOD-Bereich gibt es zurzeit zwei Strömungen eigentlich. Die eine Strömung, die man besser gesagt auch als Stau bezeichnen könnte, weil es keine Strömung ist, ist auf Seiten der Majors, die sehr desorientiert sind. Alle wissen, okay, Music On The Mount wird irgendwann einen Marktanteil haben, und zwar einen gar nicht unwesentlichen Marktanteil. Auf der anderen Seite haben sie ihre Verpflichtungen zum Einzelhandel. Die dürfen den nicht verschrecken, weil das ist jetzt die Hauptvertriebsschiene. Auf der anderen Seite haben sie intern extrem lange Entscheidungswege. Und man weiß auch einfach nicht, was sie hinter ihren Mauern treiben. Also ob sie jetzt in ihrem Häuschen da schon toll anfangen, ihre ganzen Files zu digitalisieren und sich auf einen LOD-Bereich vorzubereiten. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir eigentlich so die kleineren Labels, die für uns auch interessant sind, weil die freuen sich eigentlich über jeden neuen Vertriebsweg, der sich ihnen bietet. Weil das sind keine Unternehmen mit riesen Umsätzen, sondern es sind meistens kleinere Firmen von 2 bis 15 Leuten, die so ein Label betreiben. Und für die ist das natürlich ein ganz interessanter Markt, weil sich im Endeffekt für sie auch die Margen erhöhen. Also das heißt, pro verkauften Song verdienen sie im Endeffekt mehr über diesen Weg als über den klassischen.
Also ihr seid letzten Endes die, von denen wir vorhin sprachen, nämlich die, die es den Großen irgendwann mal schwer machen wird, wenn es genug von euch gibt. Dann aber relativiert sich ein Stück weit doch auch die Tatsache, dass man da was findet. Also ich stelle mir mal vor, es gibt 10.000 solche kleinen mittelständigen Betriebe, die so etwas anbieten. Dann wird es ja doch wieder irgendwie mehr oder weniger beliebig. Dann muss man ja doch wieder suchen, um Bands zu finden, eben auf solchen Hostings und so weiter. Oder ihr müsst wachsen und dann seid ihr doch wieder genau die Majors, die wir eigentlich alle gar nicht wollen, weil sie nämlich die Sachen viel zu teuer machen. Und da stellt sich mir die Frage im Vergleich zum Radio von heute. Music on Demand. Da habe ich eine Musik, da klicke ich rauf, da steht irgendein Text, da klicke ich rauf, dann spielt das oder ich kann es downloaden. Ich weiß vorher, ich kenne den Sound nicht, ich muss ihn anhören, dann höre ich ihn schlechter Qualität. So ist ja das Konzept im Prinzip. Wenn ich ihn gehört habe oder wenn ich ihn in guter Qualität haben will, und er ist kommerziell, dann muss ich ihn bezahlen. Gut, dann habe ich den auf meiner Platte. Nun raucht mein Window 95 ab. Der Song ist weg, schön blöd. Jetzt kann man sagen, CD kann auch kaputt gehen, aber CD ist nochmal was anderes, weil der Sound, den kann ich beliebig, da ist nur ein Gedankenböllchen. Das sind 001, die nicht mal physikalisch wirklich... Die muss man nicht kopieren, da muss man nicht Geld für aufwenden, um die zu kopieren. Wie legitimiert ihr im Prinzip diese Preise, die das letzten Endes kostet, wo zum Beispiel im Radio sowas umsonst kommt, da kriegt ihr den Mainstream vorgedudelt und solche Sachen?
Also ich denke erstmal ist es natürlich immer eine Geschmackssache. Leider gibt es ja in vielen Gebieten Deutschlands nicht so ein nettes Radio wie Fritz, das man wirklich durchhören kann und nicht immer abschalten muss, weil irgendwelche unhörbaren Sachen da kommen. Und ich bin zum Beispiel auf jeden Fall ein Hörer, der gerne Musik hört, die man nicht als Mainstream einordnen würde. Das heißt, mich interessiert es auch sehr, wo ich solche Musik bekomme. Und zur Zeit bekomme ich diese Musik hauptsächlich in Läden, die wenn dann in Großstädten mehr oder weniger zu finden sind. Und da muss man dann auch durch die Gegend fahren, in die Innenstadt, Parkplatz suchen etc. Das heißt, über ein Internetangebot hat man da natürlich einen wesentlich besseren Zugriff. Und bei dem System, das wir verwenden Liquid Audio, kannst du diese Fallzeit auch in Audioqualität auf CD brennen. Das heißt, du kannst sie nachher in jedem beliebigen CD-Player wieder hören.
Aber es ist nun schon so, dass das eigentlich was für die Zukunft ist, weil du sagst, du lässt den ganzen Tag das Radio laufen. Bei Fritz geht das vielleicht, da kann man geteilter Meinung drüber sein. Bei anderen Sender geht es gar nicht. Bei anderen Sendern geht es vielleicht überhaupt nicht. Aber eins sind wir sicher von euch, das schaffe ich niemals, einen ganzen Tag Musik zu hören, ohne dabei komplett arm zu werden. Das geht gar nicht. Erstens verdient die Telekom, zweitens verdient er, wenn es kommerzielle Musik ist. Da habe ich überhaupt keine Chance. Wird das nicht hinzukommen?
Aber das ist eine andere Rangensweise, weil du vergleichst jetzt Radio mit einem Plattenladen.
Nee, ich vergleiche ein Broadcast-Medium oder ein Multicast-Medium mit einem Multicast-Medium. Also Radio, ich kann eine Wunschradiosendung, da rufe ich an und sage, was ich hören will, dann spielt der das.
Ganz kurze Begriffsdefinition. Die Technik, die wir einsetzen, ist definitiv kein Broadcast-Medium. Also wir haben diesbezüglich auch die höheren Weihen von IFPI und GEMA, die uns bestätigt haben, dass wir kein Broadcast-Medium betreiben. Es ist keine Radiostation. Es ist letztendlich, wenn man jetzt mal in Terminologie der Musikbranche sprechen will, ein virtuelles Rack.
Ups, ihr klappert da immer so auf der Tastatur, deswegen habe ich es ausgemacht.
Ach so, ich dachte, das wäre schön fürs Ambiente. Unsere Hörer mögen das, Johnny.
Aber nicht lauter als der Karriere.
Vielleicht können wir an der Stelle kurz noch mal auf diese Technik eingehen. Also dieses Liquid Audio, das ist ein kommerzieller Anbieter. Ich persönlich kenne es jetzt nicht so gut. Das vereinbart irgendwie einerseits, es ist ja im Prinzip auch nur ein MPEG Audio Layer 3 Format. Oder?
Nein.
Hier?
Okay, also ganz kurz zur Technik. Liquid Audio ist halt nicht nur eine Kompressionsmethode, aber ich gehe jetzt mal kurz auf die Kompression rein. Die Kompression basiert auf Dolby Digital, was von Liquid Audio weltweit lizenziert worden ist, für den Online-Bereich. Und des Weiteren wurde ein spezielles Verfahren für sowohl den Kopierschutz, der eigentlich völlig banal auf Basis von RSA-Encryption und Zertifikaten basiert. Und andererseits aber eine Wasserzeichen-Methode, die auf Basis von Fourier-Transformationen arbeitet. Das heißt, die Schutzinformation wird in die Musik eingebaut und nicht neben der Musik abgelegt. Anders ausgedrückt, es überlebt auch analoge Kopien. Das heißt, wenn man da von Ampeg-Kopien zieht, dann kann man, wenn man diese Kopien analysiert herausfinden, wer hat diesen Song wann, wo, von wem, für wie viel gekauft.
So lange, bis das Gegenteil bewiesen wird. Also bisher haben alle Watermarking-Technologien den Hardcore-Test, soweit ich das weiß, nicht wirklich überstanden.
Also wir reden jetzt hier nicht darüber, ob nur irgendwas knackbar ist oder nicht. Das ist natürlich alles machbar.
Das ist so ein Thema, das wir uns immer interessieren. Davon mal abgesehen, was für eine Information wird mit RSA abgelegt? Also wessen Publiki finde ich denn da?
Mit RSA wird keine Information abgelegt, sondern die Musik wird mit RSA kodiert, damit man sie personifizieren kann, also mit dem Käufer verknüpfen kann. Du beziehst dich sicherlich auf das Wasserzeichen, was dafür Information drin abgelegt wird.
Ich denke mal, das Wasserzeichen ist einfach die Methode, mit der dieser RSA Kod drin steht.
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Das Wasserzeichen in der Liquid-Audio-Datei ist einfach auch noch mal die RSA Key mit drin im Header, oder was?
Nein.
Sondern?
Ich sagte doch gerade, die Musik wird encrypted und ich habe ein Public-Private-Key-Encoding-Verfahren. Und der Public-Key ist im File drin und der Private-Key ist im Player drin. Und der on the fly decodiert beim Abspielen die Musik.
Und zusätzlich...
Das Wasserzeichen, was in der Musik drin ist, enthält Informationen wie zum Beispiel erstens die Seriennummer des Encoding-Tools, damit man also auch nicht autorisierte Kopien nachverfolgen kann. Zweitens, wenn von dem Anbieter, das heißt von der Musikindustrie, der in die Information zur Verfügung gestellt wurde, der sogenannte ISRC-Code, das ist ein international gültiger Katalogcode für die Katalysierung von Musikstücken. Die können eindeutig dann identifiziert werden, wo gehört das hin, wer hat die Rechte daran. Des Weiteren, wenn eine kommerzielle Transaktion stattfindet, es gibt ja auch kostenlose Musik, dann wird eine sogenannte Transaktionskennung, die weltweit eindeutig ist, mit einkodiert und auf Basis dieser Transaktionskennung kann ich je nach Rechtslage in dem jeweiligen Land, in Deutschland wäre z.B. eine richterliche Anordnung dafür nötig, herauskriegen, wer verbirgt sich hinter dieser kommerziellen Transaktion auf gut deutsch, wer hat das Ding gekauft. Das heißt, dass werden also keine personenbezogene Daten transferiert.
Aber glaubt ihr denn auf lange Sicht, dass so etwas Bestand haben wird? Ich gehe davon aus, in drei bis fünf Jahren, da haben wir alle mindestens 128 Kilo Bestandsleitung. Ich habe eine Festplatte, das ist eine einzige Festplatte, 150 Gigabyte oder noch mehr, da passen tausend und noch mehr Stunden Musik drauf. Ich und meine Freunde, wir kaufen Musik, dateln die darauf und meine Kumpels, sie dürfen alle auf meinen Server und ich darf auf deren Server. Wir haben innerhalb, dann nehmen wir Radiomedien dazu, dann nehmen wir die Sachen auf, die werden automatisch erkannt, klassifiziert in eine Datenbank geschrieben. Meine Kumpels und ich, der Chaos Computer Club oder wer auch immer, wir haben innerhalb von einem Jahr, haben wir alles an Musik, was es irgendwie hörbar, hörenswert gibt, auf einem gemeinsamen, gescherten Server. Das ist ein internes Private Network, keiner kann da ran. Das geht auch verschlüsselt. Wir haben überhaupt keinen Bedarf an so einem Service. Wie seht ihr das?
Ich denke mal, das was du gerade beschrieben hast, würde ich trotzdem noch als eine relativ kleine Gruppierung sehen. Also wenn ich sehe, was zur Zeit, was gerade so den Kaufmarkt ausmacht, das sind natürlich immer noch die Leute, die CDs bzw. den Müll kaufen. Und auch jetzt kann man natürlich so eine CD in den Brenner legen, bzw. ins Raumlaufwerk, dann sagt man Go und dann wird davon eine CD-Kopie gemacht. Und ich denke, in bestimmten Kreisen, sagen wir so, wenn ich 16 wäre und mir den Brenner leisten würde, dann käme ich vielleicht auf die Idee, mit fünf Freunden eine Reihe um die CDs zu kaufen. Und dann hat man sie auch sehr preis.
Aber jetzt sind doch eure Kunden, die jetzt das machen würden, jetzt erstmal genau auch das Klientel, das genau so etwas macht, nämlich Leute, die Musik übers Internet kaufen.
Ne, das glaube ich nicht. Ich kann dazu insofern was sagen, als dass man glaube ich von der wartet, die sich viel mit dem Internet beschäftigt und viel mit Computern beschäftigt, dass man eine ganze Menge Sachen immer wieder unterschätzt. Und das ist unter anderem die Bedienbarkeit von Computern, die Bedienbarkeit von Internetdienstleistungen und von anderen Sachen. Also ich weiß, dass du es vielen Leuten einfach extrem einfach machen musst. Und dass viele Leute, das kommt natürlich, wir müssen auch mal über Geld reden, weil wir wissen, dass die Telekom für einen Song z.B. technische Verfahren, ich schieb's immer weg, weil ich find's so langweilig, aber da kann ein Song so durchaus um die 8, 9 Mark kosten, was ich viel zu teuer finde. Das ist, wenn das preislich okay ist, dann werden sich eine Menge Leute durch einen Mausklick und durch Abbuchen von 2, 3, 4, 5 Mark nicht davon abbringen lassen, die werden nicht anfangen, Private Network aufzubauen dafür.
Nein, das haben sie dann ja sowieso. Also wenn das auch, das ist dann ja auch genauso praktisch wie diese Technologie.
Darf ich mal ganz kurz nochmal auf die Frage eingehen, jetzt unter Berücksichtigung der, sagen wir mal, Erfordernisse und Ängste der Musikindustrie und jetzt meine ich die Majors, also wirklich die großen, die den Markt beherrschen. Mit diesen privaten Netzwerken und den privaten Kopien, die da erstellt werden, haben die überhaupt kein Problem. Das selbe Argument wird immer wieder verwandt. Es wurde verwandt, als die Kassette erfunden wurde. Es wurde verwandt als die CD-ROM, also der Rohling, den man sich da selber beschreiben kann, erfunden wurde und so weiter und so fort. Prinzipiell haben die, was die Wirtschaftlichkeit, also die potenziellen Verluste oder Nicht-Gewinne, so sollte man es ja vielleicht besser bezeichnen, haben sie nicht so sehr das Problem damit. Das Problem haben sie damit, wenn einer sich ein paar tausend oder ein paar hunderttausend Kopien von etwas macht und das dann wirklich über Ladenketten oder auf der Straße verramscht. Darum geht es letztendlich. Es geht nicht um den Consumer, der sich ein, zwei oder drei private Kopien zieht. Das hat die Musikindustrie sich schon lange abgeschminkt.
Aber die machen das doch trotzdem.
Wenn ich mal dazwischen werfen kann, werden die MP3-Sites nicht alle abgemahnt im Moment, die sich nirgendswo announced haben. Nein, aber das ist doch eigentlich das Gleiche. Also gut, das ist der Skopiesgröße. Aber normalerweise ist doch so eine MP3-Site überhaupt nicht bekannt. Und wenn sie bekannt wird, dann muss sie wegen der im Trafik allein schon schließen. Das heißt, das kann man auch im Grunde sagen, dass nur ein paar Leute, die das da kriegen, fertig.
Da möchte ich mich ganz kurz darauf eingehen, bezugnehmend auf das Telefonat mit dem Herrn von der Fraunhofer Gesellschaft. Die Frage, die da gestellt wurde, wer steckt denn eigentlich dahinter, dass er jetzt plötzlich anfängt zu lizenzieren, die Musikindustrie oder so. Und er meinte, nein, nein. Er hat dann aber gesagt, wer dahinter steckt. Nämlich die GEMA unter anderem. Also es gibt ein Projekt von den Verwertungsgesellschaften international. Das nennt sich Enabling Software. Das Enabling Software Projekt, zuständig bei der GEMA hier in Deutschland, ist dafür ein der Alexander Wolf. Und von der FP ein Herr, wie heißt er?
Schäfer?
Schäfer, genau. Dr. Schäfer. Und die haben eine Taskforce mit über 30 Leuten aufgesetzt. Und die machen nichts weiter, als das gesamte Netz nach MPEG-Files und entsprechenden Servern durchzusuchen. Und es geht ihnen letztendlich nicht darum, jetzt die Leute zu verknacken. Das tun sie zwar, also sie mahnen sie ab. Und diese ganzen Geschichten passieren ja tatsächlich. Aber der Hintergrund ist eigentlich ein Politischer. Sie möchten die Herstellerfirmen, die es gibt, für Kodierungen, egal ob das jetzt Audio-Soft ist oder MPEG mit Frauen-UV oder Liquid Audio, wem auch immer, sie sprechen jeden an und sagen, wir wollen, dass ihr mit uns einen Vertrag schließt, dass ihr nur über Lizenzen arbeitet und wir im Zweifelsfall herauskriegen können, wer von euch diese Lizenzen hat. Darum geht es. Das ist der politische Hintergrund dieser Geschichte.
Das steht im Prinzip vergleichbar mit dem Druck, der auf die Hersteller von CD-Playern und DAT-Recordern und so weiter gemacht wurde, damit sie keinen digitalen Kopierschutz und so weiter mit reinbauen. Ich denke auch, das ist so der Trend, dass so grundsätzlich irgendwie, ich meine, dieser Raubkopierermarkt ist echt kein Problem. Das denke ich auch. Diese Größenordnungen, die da immer wieder genannt werden, übrigens ja auch in der Softwareindustrie von Microsoft, irgendwie, dass ja so und so viele Millionen Schaden entstanden sei, dadurch, dass jetzt irgendwie Raubkopien gezogen werden, das ist alles totaler Töne. Aber im Prinzip läuft es eben darauf hinaus, dass diese großen Companies versuchen, sich ihren Markt zu erhalten, auf diese Art und Weise.
Was ja auch irgendwie verständlich ist, weil bestimmte Mechanismen aber nicht richtig verstanden werden. Also das ist so wie die ganzen Plattenläden und wie jetzt Klagen um Gottes Willen, wenn jetzt Musik auch noch digital vertrieben wird. Also wer drei Schritte weiter denkt, der weiß, dass er gerade als kleiner Laden eine enorme Chance hat plötzlich, nämlich ein viel größeres Publikum zu erreichen und eine ganz andere Distributionsform zu finden. Also die Läden brauchen eigentlich keine Angst haben, die müssen nur ein bisschen mitdenken. Aber die Geschichte mit der GEMA ist natürlich eine andere. Und da ist die Frage, obwohl ich von denen immer noch Geld kriege, bin ich nicht so ein richtig großer Freund der GEMA. Weil ich finde, das ist eine doch sehr institutionalisierte Geschichte. Also der hakt inzwischen an einigen Punkten. Das ist von der Grundidee natürlich völlig richtig. Aber die GEMA sagt zum Beispiel ja auch, wir kümmern uns um die Urheberrechte. Und dann ist es natürlich auch verständlich, dass sie sich jetzt auch im digitalen Bereich kümmern, indem sie sagen, warte mal, hier, wir vertreten, weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen Künstler. Und deswegen müssen wir uns darum jetzt kümmern. Es gibt bestimmt auch Musiker, die da nicht so locker sind und die nicht sagen, super, dann hören mehr Leute meine Musik, sondern die zu GEMA gehen und sagen, warum kümmert ihr euch nicht darum?
Die GEMA kümmert sich ja auch drum. Also auf der Popcom haben sie da irgendwie, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was da konkret dahinter steckt. Auf jeden Fall gab es diese tollen Schleier, wo drauf zu lesen war, ja, wir haben jetzt auch Server im Betrieb, die dann auch irgendwie MP3-Server abkrasen und die mir dann die Tante von der GEMA irgendwie erklärt, ja, und dann verklagen wir dann den, der da auf der Seite drauf steht.
Dazu kann man so ein bisschen was sagen.
Ja, die Domänen und so.
Ein paar nette Facts, also diese Task Force mit 30 Mitarbeitern, die zum Beispiel gegen illegale Impact-Falls vorgeht, hat jetzt, also die...
Und ist das die?
Wie heißt die FPE?
FPE ist der internationale Phono-Verband, wo die ganzen größeren Plattenfirmen meistens zusammengeschlossen sind. Und die GEMA hat Urheberrechtswahrung. Und letztens haben die halt Zahlen, die bringen immer so Zahlen raus, wen sie wieder erwischt haben mit 5 Tonnen gebrannten Bootlegs und so weiter. Und die witzige Zahl für einen Monat dieser Task Force waren 25 abgemahnte Impact-Files. Also wenn man so die Relation sieht, ist das natürlich einfach absurd.
Die haben halt keine Ahnung vom Internet.
Wie lang waren eigentlich die Amis?
Also ich bin mit einem anderen Projekt halt auch schon seit zwei Jahren mit der GEMA im Gespräch. Und ich denke, einen Großteil des Know-Hows haben sie auch durch diese Gespräche erlangt. Also es ist wirklich ein bisschen schwierig, mit diesen Leuten da über moderne Medien zu reden. Was auch noch dazu kommt, ist halt, dass die Mitarbeiter teilweise sehr unbeweglich sind. Also in so einem Status und in so einer Hierarchie gefangen sind, dass sie sich auch kaum bewegen können. Aber was ich irgendwie nochmal so als anderen Aspekt sagen will, was ich zum Beispiel sehr witzig finde, wie die Industrie auch auf sowas reagieren kann, wenn da ein paar Köpfe dabei sind, die halt ein bisschen nach vorne denken, ist zum Beispiel, dass auf der mpeg3.com Seite seit einer Woche oder so ein Werbebanner zur neuen Hole CD ist. Und zwar bewirbt dieses Werbebanner auf der MPEG3-Site einen kommerziellen Download per Liquid Audio. Und das finde ich einfach unheimlich clever.
Weil es ist vollkommen klar, dass alle Leute mpeg3.com mp3.com oder MP?
Dass die wissen, da gehen die Leute hin, die Musik hören wollen.
Wir haben ja immer Software mit Musik verglichen und das ist ja auch gar nicht so ein blöder Vergleich. Also wir können ja nachher noch mal über diese Free- und Shareware-Idee nachdenken. Bei den Amis, bei bestimmten Servern, wo man MP3-Files kriegt, die definitiv nicht legal dastehen, da gibt es ja so einen Disclaimer dann, also so ein Hinweis, und da wird gesagt, dass die Files hier alle nur als Backup dienen, das heißt, du darfst dir die runterladen, wenn du die Original-CD sozusagen zu Hause stehen hast. Und das ist natürlich von den Betreibern der Server ein Weg drumrum, ist völlig klar. Gibt es dieses Gesetz in Deutschland auch? Darf ich von meiner Musik ein privates Backup machen?
Also der Disclaimer ist natürlich inhaltlich nicht korrekt. Das ist völlig klar. Sondern womit da gespielt wird, ist letztendlich die Unfähigkeit der, sagen wir mal, Behörden oder sonstigen verfolgenden Organisationen, GMA, FP und Konsorten, zu beweisen, dass das keine private Kopie ist. Denn man kann ja nicht beweisen, ob man die selbst gemacht hat oder ob man die aus dem Internet runtergeladen hat. Das ist der Background. Dann sagt man, nee, die hab ich mir selber gemacht, nur als Sicherheit, wenn man eine CD verbrennt oder so. Aber eigentlich inhaltlich korrekt ist es nicht.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie, das sind so Wege um die Justiz. Das ist so wie, wenn ich bei Hotline zum Beispiel einen Server will, dann steht da als erstes, wenn ich hier auf Accept klicke, also auf Akzeptieren, dann sage ich damit, dass ich, weiß ich nicht, kein Mitglied der, des FBI bin und des CIA und, dass ich nur hier bin, um mich mal umzugucken und nichts Böses tue. Und ich glaube, in Amerika funktioniert sowas tatsächlich. Man kann dann hinterher glaube ich tatsächlich sagen, wieso, das steht da vorne, der hat da rauf geklickt und jetzt kommt er an und sagt, das ist das CIA, dann hat er sich eigentlich schon strafbar gemacht.
Vielleicht noch eine andere Frage, es gibt so öfters Disclaimer, da steht dann drauf, ja, darf man downloaden, aber nach 24 Stunden löschen. Vielleicht, wenn wir jetzt mal einen Experten da haben, ist denn sowas so lacherhaft, wie es für mich aussieht oder ist da was hinter?
Also die Frage ist, ob das technisch überhaupt machbar ist?
Nein, ob das greift, also ob das irgendwas aussagt oder ob das sowieso...
Also ob das juristisch greift, kann ich natürlich nicht sagen. Wir setzen eine Technologie ein, mit der man sowas voreinstellen kann und deshalb brauche ich mich da eigentlich nicht weiter drum zu kümmern. Wenn ich sage, dass das fein bloß einen Tag Gültigkeit hat, dann ist es auch nur einen Tag gültig.
Ja klar, das meint die nicht, ich wollte halt wissen, vielleicht wusste es ja jemand mit der Juba.
Im Chat gab es die Frage, was ist, wenn ich einen Songfall kommerziell kaufe und meine Platte kackt ab und das CD-Backup ist mir auch kaputt gegangen. Also man muss natürlich irgendwann mal sagen, wenn mir mein Computer vom Tisch knallt und er ist kaputt, dann habe ich auch ein bisschen Pech gehabt.
Also wenn mir meine CD kaputt geht.
Nee, das ist aber kein Argument, weil in zwei, drei Jahren, Moment, in zwei, drei Jahren wird es so sein, dass ich, oder in fünf, dass ich nicht mehr unterscheide zwischen meiner lokalen Festplatte und einer Festplatte bei einem Service-Anbieter.
Dann wird sicher auch ein Weg gehen, dass wenn du das mal gekauft hast, dann wieder heute das Lüsten wieder kriegst.
Das ist genau der Punkt, dass ich einfach das Recht erwerbe, eine Musik zu hören und zwar auf Lebenszeit. Das ist eine Erinnerung, die ich erinnere mich halt auf dem Server und nicht mehr im Kopf, so wie ich mich heute auf der CD an die Musik erinnere. Ich hab die ja nicht perfekt im Kopf, wenn ich sie nicht dauernd höre oder im Bücherregal an Content oder im Köpfen von anderen an bestimmte Sachverhalte. Ich weiß, der weiß das. So, das ist ja Erinnern in jemand anderem.
Sag ich nochmal, also ganz kurz provokativ, was zu ist natürlich auch eine Sache des Preises. Also theoretisch ist es im MoD Bereich natürlich auch möglich, dass du sagst, okay, der Song kostet 50 Pfennig, aber den kannst du nur drei Monate hören. Danach müsstest du ihn nochmal neu kaufen. Also es ist alles möglich sozusagen. Ich denke auch, dass da einfach ein neuer Markt mit sehr eigenen Mechanismen entstehen wird. Also auch sowohl in der Preisgestaltung als auch in solchen Speicherfragen etc.
Wie sieht es denn überhaupt, lass uns erstmal kurz ein bisschen Musik, mal kurz wieder ein bisschen Luft holen über alles nachdenken, was wir gerade gehört haben. Super, wir haben uns gerade auf Spielregeln geraten. Die greifen aber jetzt noch nicht. Es gibt einen, wir reden jetzt noch einmal über einen Sicherheitsaspekt bzw. über einen legalen Aspekt und dann hab ich 30.000 mal gesagt, Telekom, da reden wir gleich noch mal drüber, wenn wir dann auch nochmal anreißen und den Unterschied von der Telekom zu dem Verfahren bzw. zu dem, was Movabit macht, ein bisschen rausstellen.
Gut, also wir sind hier natürlich eine Hacker-Sendung, unter anderem unsere Zielgruppe will bedient sein. Eine Sache muss noch erwähnt sein, an der Stelle, nämlich wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass der Encoder eine Seriennummer durch irgendwelche Verfahren, nennen wir es Fotografie oder wie auch immer, vielleicht findet sich da noch was tolles, encodet und damit einen Watermark einbaut in meine Software, dann zieht das genau so lange, wie irgendein Hacker kommt, der einfach zu viel Zeit hat und der gerade die Schule ist aus, der sitzt zu Hause und will das jetzt tun und der kann nachweisen, dass dieses Verfahren knackbar ist. Und ich will jetzt mal konkret das Beispiel EC-Karte nennen, da ist das genau so gelaufen, da hat die Banken gesagt, ja, aber das Geld ist geklaut worden, weil ihr mit eurer PIN nicht gut umgegangen seid und sobald das erst mal nachgewiesen werden kann, dass dieses Verfahren eben doch nicht so sicher ist, zieht das vor Gericht als Beweis nicht und dann kann kein Raubkopierer verknackt werden, weil einfach gezeigt werden kann, dass das Watermark fälschbar gewesen ist und das kann dann getan worden sein und damit kann man natürlich irgendwelche Anscheinbeweise machen, da liegt viel Musik rum und der hat die CD gar nicht, aber der Beweis ist nicht mehr zwingend, dass jemand, der eine Software hat, wo eine Seriennummer drin steht von jemand anderem, sie dann auch von diesem anderen haben kann. Und dann kann man dem zwar seine Kopien wegnehmen, aber man kann den ursprünglichen Raubkopierer nicht belangen. Dieses Problem besteht einfach bei solchen Verfahren prinzipiell und solange da nicht jemand ein unknackbares Kryptografie-Verfahren findet, wo der Schlüssel nicht in der Software drin sein kann, weil sonst wäre er rausknackbar, ist dieses Problem einfach gegeben.
Ja, ich würde mal kurz darauf eingehen. Also ich denke, die Knackbarkeit muss man nicht nachweisen. Also wenn ich jetzt mal theoretisch an das Problem rangehe, dann im Gegenteil. Jeder Algorithmus ist prinzipiell knackbar. Es kommt immer noch auf den Aufwand, an den man da reinsteckt. Darum geht es letztendlich auch gar nicht. Also erst mal per se dieses Wasserzeichen gibt es wirklich nur dann, wenn eine finanzielle Transaktion stattgefunden hat. Das heißt, wenn es jemand gekauft hat. Das ist der erste Punkt. Zweitens, jemand, der es gekauft hat, ist nicht per se ein Hacker, ein Musikpirat oder sonst irgendwas. Sondern wenn jemand dann zum Beispiel die CD von jemandem, die man bekommt und davon kommerzielle Kopien erstellt, dann kann man ihm das vielleicht nachweisen. Wenn er jetzt einen Aufwand zugrunde legt, mit der also dieses Wasserzeichen rausarbeitet, und das ist sehr kompliziert, das ist sehr aufwendig, weil es ist keine Encryption.
Nein, also das war auch gar nicht der Angriff. Der Punkt ist, dass ich nur einmal nachweisen muss, dass dieses Wasserzeichen auch durch einen Softwarefehler falsch sein kann. Wenn ich das nachweisen kann, dann gilt einfach die Rückantwort nicht, dass ich ein MPEG-File oder ein Liquid-Audio-File mit diesem Wasserzeichen finde, dass ich dann sagen kann, das Wasserzeichen sagt, der da hinten war. Und in dem Moment, wenn ich die Leute nicht mehr verklagen kann, dann ist einfach die gesamte Bedrohung weg.
Es gibt vier Stellen, die miteinander korrelieren müssen. Es muss einmal das Wasserzeichen in dem Fall setzt, die Transaktionsinformation auf dem Liquid-Server, der das Fall bereitgestellt hat. Dann gibt es eine sogenannte Clearing-Stelle, das Liquid Operations Center. Da ist die Information noch mal drin mit Zusatzinformation. Und dann haben wir natürlich noch die Daten der Finanztransaktion, also entweder Abbruchung oder Kreditkarte oder T-Online-Rechnung. Und diese vier müssen übereinstimmen. Ansonsten funktioniert das sowieso nicht.
Eine kurze Frage, wäre es euch vielleicht möglich, uns da ein bisschen Dokumentation zu kommen zu lassen, damit wir in der nächsten Datenschleuder was dazu sagen können?
Ich muss mal dazu sagen, wir sind weder die Erfinder, noch die Verkäufer dieser Software, sondern wir haben sie lizenziert und benutzen sie einfach nur. Also ihr könnt euch gerne an Liquid Audio in den USA wenden.
Na ja, die IP ist aber gleichzeitig auch der europäische Vertrieb insofern.
Nicht der europäische, also für Deutschland, Schweiz und Österreich. Aber auch das, wir sind letztendlich bloß die Verkäufer von dem Zeug. Wir haben es nicht entwickelt.
Aber wisst ihr, ob die das raustun?
Ihr seid da aber näher dran.
Wir sind da näher dran und ich hab auch mit den Entwicklern gesprochen. Ich war mal da, es ist eine ganz nette Atmosphäre da. Das sind ziemlich harte Leute, also wie man sich halt so einen richtigen Hacker vorstellt.
Wie anders als wir?
Ich glaube nicht, dass die die Dokumentation dafür rausrücken. Die Amerikaner sind da extrem intensiv.
Die haben wohl Schiss, dass man da was finden könnte. Also jeder, der von einem solchen Verfahren den Source nicht freigibt, der hat eigentlich schon verloren.
Ja klar, wenn er ihn freigibt, hat er ihn aber auch verloren, weil dann kriegt er nämlich keinen Kontakt.
Weil das Verfahren schlecht ist.
Jedes Verfahren ist glaube ich nicht so schlecht.
Nein, aber die Sache ist die, warum sollte ich denn als kleine Band einem Verfahren meine tolle Musik anvertrauen, wenn der Hersteller auf meinem Verfahren selber nicht genug vertraut, um Socken zu legen?
Also wenn dieses Verfahren das einzige weltweit ist, was mir garantiert, dass ich vielleicht auch ein paar Mark verdiene, dann finde ich jetzt das eine gute Motivation.
Es geht ja gerade um die Garantie, die ja eben dann...
Mir scheint, dass hier ein erheblicher Aufwand getrieben wird, um ein Problem zu lösen, das sich vielleicht anders viel einfacher lösen lässt. Ich erinnere mal an so Beispiele Telekom, Straßenbahn und solche Dinge. Da werden Abrechnungsmechanismen, Sicherheitskontrollen, Lettys, Gerichtsverhandlungen und so weiter und so weiter eingebaut, um ein Geld einzutreiben. Das Ganze kostet unheimlich viel. Letzten Endes, wären die ganzen Sachen unendlich billig, würde ich zum Beispiel ein Abonnement haben können. Flatrate. Ich abonniere mich auf ein Genre oder auf drei, vier. Das kostet mich 25 Mark im Monat. Da fällt dieser ganze Scheiß weg, ehrlich. Du kannst damit immer noch massiv Gewinn machen. Du kannst damit Gewinner einfahren. Es lassen sich andere Gewinnmodelle auf freiwilliger Basis und so weiter geben.
Da haben wir nämlich genau den Ansatz, dass wir denken einfach auch alle noch sehr in diesen Bildern, die wir bis jetzt kennen. Was finde ich? Künstler, Plattenfirma, Vertrieb, Plattenladen.
Vielleicht mal ein Hinweis. Die Gründer dieser Firma entstanden der Band Grateful Dead.
Du meinst verliegt mit Audio jetzt oder was?
Ja, die sich dadurch hervorgetan hat, dass sie gesagt hat, kopiert unsere Scheiben, macht dafür so viele Kopien wie ihr wollt. Das tut uns überhaupt nicht weh. Und sie ist weiß Gott nicht arm geworden dabei. Joey Glass hier ist auch nicht arm gestorben.
Das ist das Problem von Frauenhofer. Die machen es genau andersrum und das fällt ihnen genau in den Rücken. Aber da müsst ihr euch dann auch fragen lassen. Ihr schiebt da jetzt nun eigentlich in dieser kommerziellen Richtung mit. Wäre es nicht schöner hier gerade bei euch als einer der mehr drei Player in diesem Land, gut, gibt einfach nicht mehr, ob ihr da groß oder klein seid, spielt keine Rolle.
Ihr könnt Signale setzen.
Ihr seid einer der drei, einer hat es schon nicht geschafft. MC Y ist irgendwie vom Fenster. Vermute ich mal, keine Ahnung. Man hört so wenig. Telekom, das ist richtig. Telekom kann ich an dem Punkt nicht wirklich ernst nehmen. Also ihr seid doch hier im Prinzip in der Lage, Signale zu setzen und seid doch da auch in der Verantwortung. Ihr gestaltet das schließlich aktiv mit.
Die Manager aus dem Major Bereich, den wir unseren Trendpool vorgeführt haben, waren ziemlich käsig im Gesicht. Muss mal ganz deutlich zu sagen.
Haben die das denn verstanden?
Das reicht uns aber auch noch ein bisschen nicht. Weil ihr wollt auf der anderen Seite trotzdem mit diesem kommerziellen und durchaus sehr teuren Bereich Geld verdienen. Also man könnte heutzutage ohne Probleme eine komplette CD mit so und soviel 15 Songs drauf für 5 Mark anbieten. Und da würdet ihr noch reichlich genug bei verdienen und andere Konzepte.
Das stimmt leider nicht. Also da können wir gerne mal durch die Kalkulationen gehen. Aber ihr wisst auch, was Traffic hier in Deutschland kostet. Na gut, das ist aber... Also ich denke mal, wir müssen so ein bisschen unterscheiden, ob wir über jetzt reden oder ob wir über in einem halben Jahr reden oder in zwei Jahren. Also ich denke mal, was ich eben schon meinte, man wird sich dem Markt anpassen und man wird auch neue Konzepte entwickeln. Also wir arbeiten zum Beispiel mit werden mit einem Zahlungsverfahren arbeiten, bei dem man auch Lastschriftverfahren machen kann. Das heißt, da könnte zum Beispiel so ein Abo-Bereich schon denkbar sein.
Aber diesen ganzen Simon mit diesem einzelnen Abrechnen und codieren und einfuhren und hast du nicht gesehen, mit Verschlüsseln, den kannst du dir komplett spielen.
Ja, aber da muss man auch so ein bisschen die Historie der Musikindustrie oder des Musikgeschäftes überhaupt sehen. Das Musikgeschäft war immer eine Sache von Lizenzen, Verwaltungsrechten, Urheberrechten etc. Deswegen ist auch diese Freeware-Shareware-Diskussion so ein bisschen abstrakt dazu. Weil zur Zeit ist es halt zum Beispiel so, Urheberrechte gelten 30 Jahre nach dem Tod. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt sogar noch verlängert worden, auf 50. Und es ist ein totales Geflecht von rechten Lizenzen usw. Wo dann auch noch dazu kommt, dass Leitungen nach wie vor noch teuer sind, Traffic teuer ist. Also es ist leider nicht so, dass wir es super billig machen können. Wir würden es gerne billiger machen, auf jeden Fall. Das ist unser Antrieb.
Gut, da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Es ist 0 Uhr 33.
Terror bei dem Anschlag im jüdischen Stadtteil von Hebron sind nach israelischen Angaben 23 Menschen verletzt worden. Zwölf der Opfer seien israelische Soldaten, 11 Palästinenser. Ein Unbekannter hatte zwei Handgranaten auf einen israelischen Armee-Jeep geschleudert. Auf Ruhe, hunderte aufgebrachter Demonstranten haben in der peruanischen Hauptstadt Lima den Präsidentenpalast gestürmt. Sie warfen Fenster ein und versuchten, Türen in Brand zu setzen. Die Sicherheitskräfte gingen mit Wasserwerfern gegen die Menge vor. Zuvor hatten rund 10.000 Menschen friedlich gegen Präsident Fujimori demonstriert. Reaktionen der Welt-Sicherheitsrat kommt heute zu einer Dringlichkeitssitzung über die Situation in der Krisenprovinz Kosovo zusammen. Hintergrund sind jüngste Berichte über Gräueltaten an Albanern. Schulterschluss, Deutschland und Frankreich wollen nach dem Machtwechsel den bonn neuen Schwung in ihre Zusammenarbeit bringen. Bei seinem Amttritt in Paris vereinbartet der künftige Bundeskanzler Schröder mit Staatspräsident Chirac die Bildung von Arbeitsgruppen zur Europapolitik. Ergebnislos die Einzelgespräche zwischen den britischen Premier Blair, dem nordirischen Protestantenführer Trimble und Schinfein Chef Adams über eine Entwaffnung der IRA haben keinen Durchbruch gebracht. Es werden weitere Verhandlungen angekündigt. Fußball in der Champions League spielte Bayern München 2 zu 2 gegen Manchester United. Torlos 0 zu 0 ging das Spiel des 1. FC Kaiserslautern beim finnischen Meister HJK Helsinki aus. Heute Nacht aufkommender Regen bei 11 bis 8 Grad, tagsüber regnerisch 10 bis 13 Grad. Stadtautobahn Berlin Tempelhof Wedding zwischen dem Kreuz Wilmersdorf und Kurfürstendamm Schwarzbacher Straße sind wegen einer Baustelle bis 5 Uhr in Richtung Nord die linke und mittlere Spur und in Richtung Süd die linke Spur gesperrt.
Das war ein Fritz Kurzinfo mit Gerrit Katheinrich.
Fritz präsentiert einen Abend mit ziemlich interessanten Melodien und Rhythmus und Spaß mit Kid Loco, mit Hooverphonic, mit Moloko, Moloko, Hoverphonic und Kid Loco live in Berlin, Samstag 10. Oktober im Glashaus der Arena.
Wir führen einfach gleich weiter, wir haben nur noch eine halbe Stunde. Ihr hört Chaos Radio in Computerplumun bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat zu hören. Heute mit einem Haufen Informationen, technisch, inhaltlich und auch rechtlich zum Thema Musik im Internet, was da auf uns zukommt. Zu Gast im Studio ist natürlich der Chaos Computer Club und Sascha und Sascha von Movabit, die ihr unter www.movabit.de oder unter www.bitpull.de findet. Da gibt es dann auch Verzweigungen, die dann zu allen händen führen. Ach, so eine Domain, kostet heute nichts mehr. Außerdem gibt es natürlich jetzt noch ein bisschen Zeit für das hier.
Die Fris-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Bevor wir gleich noch ein paar Sachen zu dem Thema sagen, wenn ihr hier anruft, bitte folgende Spielregeln, weil wir extrem wenig Zeit haben. Als erstes möchte ich von euch wissen, wenn ihr Musik direkt im Internet kaufen könnt, wie viel ist euch ein Song wert? Also was würdet ihr für ein Lied, das ihr in CD-Qualität auf euren Rechner bekommt, nehmen wir mal jetzt von Kopiersachen ausgenommen, wie viel würdet ihr dafür bezahlen pro Song? Ist das 50 Pfennig, ist das eine Mark, 2 Mark, 3 Mark, 4 Mark, 5 Mark? Und zwar realistisch, jetzt keine Quatschantworten, bitte. Zweite Frage ist dann eure Frage. Also stellt kurz die Frage an uns, an Chaos Computer Club, an Moveabit. Und dann nehmen wir euch aus der Leitung, beantworten die Fragen und nehmen den nächsten ran, weil sonst schaffen wir noch genau einen Anrufer. 031 für Potsdam, 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. Und jetzt wollte Steini noch was sagen.
Genau, ich wollte noch was loswerden, das ist mir unendlich wichtig. Wir waren gerade bei den Kosten und dass irgendwie 5 Mark für eine CD nicht machbar sind. Da würde ich gerne mal zur Diskussion stellen, ob Bands, Musiker, die unheimlich viel Geld verdienen, deswegen auch unheimlich viel bessere Musik machen. Weil ich glaube nämlich mehr, dass die Musik Mainstream, das was Geld bringt, deswegen gehört wird, weil sie Leute dauernd hören, dass es ein Gewöhnungsinfekt ist.
Sehr lange Diskussion.
Ja, aber ich würde sie trotzdem gerne führen, weil ich glaube, dass wir, aber ich will sie zumindest ins Bewusstsein rufen, dass ich glaube, dass man mit Musik machen sehr wohl Geld verdienen kann, aber dass das nicht 100 Millionen Mark sein müssen, sondern dass ich mit 2.000, 3.000, 5.000 Mark im Monat locker klarkomme als Musiker, vielleicht sogar kreativer bin, weil ich einfach mehr den Anspruch habe. Ja, es ist einfach so, dass ich einen Anspruch verwirkliche und nicht das Ding, ich will hier Asche machen. Darum geht es beim Musik machen.
Aber diese Unterscheidungen gibt es ja beim Musik machen sowieso. Ich finde, es gibt einmal die Musik, die darauf ausgerichtet ist, viel zu verkaufen. Das sind Leute, die dann und durchaus auch in ihrem Heimstudio sitzen und dann so, weiß nicht, ich muss jetzt keine Namen nennen, aber halt so Produkte auf den Markt schmeißen. Also die du auch im Radio dann auch nur zwei Wochen lang hörst. Und dann gibt es Leute, die darin eine, die sich da eine ganz andere Welt erschaffen mit dem, was man. Und das hört man auch.
Aber die Qualität der Musik, die ist ja nicht irgendwie linear zum Geld, das die Leute dafür schieben.
Nein, das hat ja keiner.
Und deswegen wird es in Zukunft mit dem Medium Internet viel mehr so sein, dass ich eine Chance habe, unheimlich viel gute Musik zu hören, die fast nichts kostet, weil die Leute einfach mit 3-4.000 Mark im Monat zufrieden sind und nicht Hunderttausende brauchen wie Michael Jackson oder irgendein anderer Affe.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut ihr euch im Musikerbereich auskennt. Da kennt sich Johnny, glaube ich, auch besser aus. Also ich denke, die meisten Musiker, die ich kenne, wären sehr zufrieden, wenn sie 3-5.000 Mark pro Monat hätten.
Ja, aber das liegt doch genau an der Struktur, wie wir sie haben. Dass die Labels einfach die Großen promoten, die, die sich gut verkaufen lassen.
Aber so einfach ist das nicht. Also das ist wirklich nicht so einfach. Ich kann ja wirklich aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, dass es einfach gibt, unterschiedliche Arten Musik zu hören. Es gibt Leute, die wollen, sagen wir mal jetzt, man kann Musik ja auch nicht qualitativ messen. Es gibt Leute, die wollen gute, andere, inspirierte Musik hören und es gibt Leute, die wollen, guck dir an, was die Leute für Autos fahren.
Hey, ist klar, aber dafür muss der, das Label nicht so viel Geld verdienen und dafür muss der Hersteller nicht so viel Geld verdienen.
Das ist klar. Das ist nicht schlecht daran, dass man auch, wenn man Musiker ist, irgendwie Lust daran hat, viel Geld zu verdienen. Das können wir weder verhindern können, noch irgendwie können wir diese Realität ignorieren.
Vielleicht mal ganz kurzer Hinweis zu den Strukturen, wie solche Dinge laufen. Also wenn jetzt eine Produktionsfirma, ein Tonträger beschließt, jemanden zu produzieren, das heißt CDs auf den Markt zu bringen, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass dieses Produkt dann auch ein Marketingetat bekommt. Und unabhängig von der Qualität der Musik, an dem hängt es. Wenn ich ein Etat von 10 Millionen habe, dann kann ich auch ein Charted produzieren. Also nicht produzieren im Sinne von Studio und Presswerk und so, sondern markttechnisch produzieren.
Und das ist aber doch das, was die Labels jetzt eigentlich tun.
Ja, wobei es gibt auch immer Gegenbeispiel. Also es ist nicht nur so, dass ich meine, Sascha war 10 Jahre bei EFA und da gab es was? Ach, Hörer, ja gut, dann lass ich mal Hörer ran.
Hallo Hörer.
Ah, du bist so aufgeregt.
Auch aufgeregt. Ja, dich auch. Hallo Hörer. Hi, da bist du. Robert, was findest du ist angemessen als Bezahlung für ein Lied von deiner Lieblingsband?
Also, unbekannte Band, wenn es richtig kickt, höchstens 3 Mark, aber ansonsten normal so 50 Pfennig.
Also 50 Pfennig?
Sobald sie in der Nacht im Radio läuft, dann auch 10 Pfennig.
Also gut, Radio ist ja, sagen wir mal, bleibt umsonst, sagen wir mal, im weitesten Sinne durch Werbung finanziert.
Find ich einen saugeilen Ansatz zu sagen, dass was man sowieso die ganze Zeit wird, das muss auch billig sein, Angebot und Nachfrage. Find ich super, also find ich jetzt echt mal einen Hinweis.
Na ja, das haut aber hinten und vorne deswegen nicht hin, weil warum sind Leute dann nicht bereit, für Independentplatten oder Importe viel Geld zu bezahlen? Phil Collins kriegen sie doch billiger als die neue XY.
In der Diskussion sind wir doch eben schon weitergekommen. Was ist denn die Frage?
Ja, und hast du noch eine Frage an uns?
Na nö, vielleicht mal ein Hinweis für kostenlose Musik. Es war nicht MP3, aber größtenteils Trackerfiles.
Das ist bei www.cosmic.org. Das heißt Cosmic Free Music Foundation.
Die bieten von unbekannten Musikern richtig gute Musik.
Zum Beispiel kann man, wenn sich jemand dafür interessiert, mal nach Musik von Placid suchen. Der ist absolut unbekannt, macht keine Platten, sondern nur so eine Trackerfile.
Die kann man sich da downloaden, kostenlos, alles.
Mit vorne und hinten? Da steht irgendwie was ganz Komisches.
Dann Enter the Sight ist da, muss man nochmal klicken.
Nee, da steht irgendwie, das muss ja immer selber, Compass Holidays ist da.
Ich zippe das selber mal ein, dann guck ich.
Super, dass das doch klappend in den Spiegel geht.
Eben hast du C gesagt. Das ist was anderes.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es.
Ich danke für den Hinweis. So.
Und alles auf dem Chaosradio, Ticker, Feedback übrigens. Hallo, wer ist da?
Toni, was ist dir ein Song wert, deiner Lieblingsband?
Ja, ich schätze ungefähr eine Mark bis zwei Mark, kommt ganz drauf an auf die Musik. Aber auch auf die Länge des Tracks, wenn das so eine Riesen-Maxi-Version ist. Zehn Minuten bezahle ich dann gern, drei Mark oder so.
Okay, also im Moment sind wir so bei 50, wenn ich bis drei Mark. Und deine Frage an uns?
Ja, wie sieht denn die Situation mit den MP3-Codecs aus, die jetzt gerade im Umlauf sind? Der Fraunhofer hat doch gerade alles wieder zurückgezogen oder die haben rumgemault, dass die Freeware-Encoder da von dort runter soll.
Das ist später eingeschaltet, ne?
Wir hatten vor einer halben Stunde interviewt am Telefon mit dem Fraunhofer-Institut zu dem Thema.
Wollte ich noch einmal darauf hinweisen, die ganzen Tracker-Groups, der genannt hat, Cosmic mit K, sehr gut, die benutzen auch MP3-Clips auf ihren Sites. Das ist eigentlich auch ganz gut umkommen, aber ich kenne eigentlich keinen, der Freeware-Encoder benutzt, weil die sehr schlecht sind.
Okay, da hatten wir vorhin eine Menge zum Thema. Vielleicht dann einfach nochmal irgendwie zusehen, dass du dann später mal in die Real-Audio-Astief-Datei reinhörst.
Ja, gerne, ich habe einen Ruhig-Account, das geht auch.
Okay, Dank dir, Tschüss.
Eigentlich gibt es ja gar keine Freeware-Encoder mehr, wenn man das jetzt sozusagen...
Was ist denn mit Shockwave eigentlich? Was denn, also das Plug-in für...
Läuft nicht auf Linux.
ist MP3. Wieso läuft das nicht auf Linux?
Gutes?
Nein, es gibt irgendwie eine Implementation, einen Anfang, der kann bisher JPG darstellen und Koordinaten. Diese Kommerzprogramme haben immer das Problem, dass sie auch windlos laufen und fertig.
Nein, es geht um Streaming Audio.
Nein, Streaming Audio wird nicht unterstützt von dem Teil, weil es einfach nicht von dem Hersteller kommt. Der Hersteller, das ist genau wie mit Musik. Die Leute, die viel...
Moment, wir reden über zwei verschiedene Sachen.
Nein, es gibt ein Plug-in, was Flash anzeigen sollen könnte und das kann...
Nein, es geht nicht um Flash. Es geht um Shockwave-Streaming Audio. Und wenn ich das Plug-in bei Sound-Audio benutze, dann gibt es dann einen MPEG-3-Fall. Also so mache ich MP3s.
Ja, das glaube ich dir, aber es gibt Shockwave überhaupt nicht.
Du brauchst Shockwave nicht, du hast einen MP3-Fall. Shockwave-Streaming-Audio ist nichts anderes als MP3.
Der Chaos Computer Club lernt was, ich glaube es nicht.
Na ja, wir wissen ja auch nicht alles.
Ich glaube, das hat mir einer von euch erzählt.
Es gibt noch mehr von uns.
So, die Preisnurse für Musik im Internet, interessant für die Jungs von Moveabit, bleibt bei 50, wenn ich bis 3 mag, weil ansonsten hat hier keiner mehr was dazu zu sagen. Ab morgen kosten also alle Lieder 3 Mark. Das heißt, eine CD mit 12 Songs kostet euch dann 36 Mark. Worüber beschwert ihr euch eigentlich? 0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110 ist unsere Nummer. Falls jemand andere Preisvorstellungen hat, dann könnt ihr noch hier anrufen.
Weißt du eigentlich, wie viel CD ich für ein Lied gekauft hab?
Ja, das ist genau der Punkt. Wer ist denn da? Nicht mal zum Hallo sagen habt ihr Mut genug. 0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110. Ach, dann haben wir Feierabend, oder? Können wir noch ein bisschen plaudern?
Ja, also man könnte jetzt mal fairerweise auf diesen Thema, sehr verwandte Veranstaltungen, in der nächsten Woche hinweisen.
Genau.
Der Verein Mikro, der monatlich immer am ersten Mittwoch des Monats, passenderweise wir ja immer am letzten Mittwoch, die machen also immer am ersten Mittwoch im Monat ihre Veranstaltungen in der Lounge des BMFs. Wie heißt die Straße? Johannesstraße. Die machen da immer so regelmäßige Veranstaltungen mit Diskussionen und Vorträgen. Just in der nächsten Woche geht es eben um das Problem mit Urheberrechtsschutz im Internet und Musik und alles, was halt damit zu tun hat. Da wird ein interessantes Video gezeigt. Also ich gehe zumindest davon aus, dass es interessant ist. Hab es noch nicht gesehen. Das ist auch immer ganz gut besucht. Und auf jeden Fall eine gute Ergänzung zu dem, was wir jetzt hier schon mal so grob angerissen haben, wir lassen ja auch eben immer alles offen.
Und hier gibt es noch ein paar Preisvorstellungen jetzt. Hi, wer ist denn da? Jan, was ist dir ein Song wert? Maximal eine Mark?
Ich hätte immer noch eine wichtige Frage.
Ich habe vor kurzem was über neue Codierverfahren gelesen. Von Yamaha ist es glaube ich, dass noch wesentlich besser sein soll als MP3. Allerdings auch sehr viel länger braucht es.
Du weißt da was drüber, Sascha?
Ja, wir haben es eben auch gerade im Chat erfahren und dann mal kurz auf die Seite geguckt. VQF heißt das ganze Verfahren wohl. Viel mehr weiß ich da jetzt auch nicht drüber, aber die Seite, worüber ihr das erfahren könnt, und hier kommt auch noch was.
Also es gibt so auch, da steht ein bisschen mehr. Ja, es gibt also, das ist bisher, soweit ich weiß, ist das ein ziemlicher Blaststandard, weil da gibt es zwar viel Hype zu, aber die Leute haben noch nichts öffentlich, außer... Also in Kroda gibt es noch gar nichts, soweit ich weiß. In die Kroda will wohl jemand haben, aber irgendwie das reicht noch nicht, um das zu evaluieren. Und deswegen sagen wir dazu erst mal noch nichts.
Hallo Andreas, was ist dir ein Song wert?
Naja, 50 fände ich da über so knapp eine Mark, würde ich sagen.
Okay, 50 fände ich bis eine Mark.
Ich hab noch was zu dem Thema. Ich war vor kurzem mal in Russland gewesen. Und die sind da in der Richtung von ganz schön weit, will ich sagen. Ich hab da eine CD erstanden, voll nach MP3. Und so wie ich das Ding reinschiebe in den Rechner, läuft das Ding los. Und ich kann zwischen 10 Original-CDs auswählen. Und die laufen alle fein in wunderbarem Stereo. Ja, mit Sicherheit. Aber die gibt's im Laden zu kaufen. Das ist hier umgerechnet, knapp.
Ja, in Russland. Da gibt's auch immer schöne CDs im Regal, wo auch eine komplette Software-Palette von Microsoft.
Und natürlich Malaysia ist auch nicht schlecht.
Nee, aber immerhin, ich hab fast den ganzen Tag Musik von einer CD, ne?
Und dazu brauchst du dann keinen Gig-Win-Audi oder sowas, ne?
Nee, das ist gleich mit rauf und das wird über Autostart gestartet.
Das läuft einfach los, super praktisch, kein Problem. Irgendwie werden wir echt kriegen, sowas.
Der ist auch über Internet, oder? Ja, der läuft auch sehr schön.
So, alle nach Russland.
Habt nach Russland geklaut.
Die Wechselkurse sind doch da sehr verführend.
Jetzt kriegt man in Russland auch noch ganz andere Sachen, die man hier nicht kriegt. Also, dass man mal am Rande hört.
Dieses Shockwave, ich meine, wie soll man denn dieses Shockwave ernst nehmen? Da klickt man sich tot auf diesem Scheiß-Server und findet nicht einen Satz zu der Technik.
Nichts.
Natürlich nicht. Die werden ja nicht sagen, dass das einfach ein Pack ist.
Ja, das ist einfach braun.
Tim, was ist dir ein Song wert?
Jedenfalls keine drei Mark. Das wollte ich nämlich sagen. Also, drei Mark insofern vollkommen überzogen. Als das, wenn ich eine CD kaufe, sind da zehn, zwölf Songs drauf. Wenn ich die jetzt im Versand kaufe, zahle ich 25 Mark oder halt im Laden 30 Mark. Das heißt, der Song kommt mich im Schnitt sogar noch teurer. Da habe ich noch nicht mal Artwork oder solche Sachen.
Der Erste, der über sowas nachdenkt. Danke dir. Ja, da sollte man wirklich mal ausrechnen. Was kostet denn ein Song im Moment auf einer CD, wo wir doch alle meinen und auch wissen und da bin ich ganz vorne mit dabei, dass eine CD viel zu teuer ist. Dann kann man mal ein bisschen rumrechnen und dann sind wir definitiv unter drei Mark.
Sie ist vor allem irgendwie viel zu teuer für die Häufigkeit und Regelmäßigkeit, mit der ich sie nutze. Ich kaufe mir zwar so CDs, aber die meisten liegen einfach in den nächsten 20 Jahren erstmal im Schrank.
Aber da geht es nicht. Ich gebe im Monat sicher...
Doch, es geht genau danach, was ich für einen Wert habe. Das ist ja der Punkt, den ich auch finde.
Das weißt du bei einem Buch auch nicht, wenn es dir nicht gefällt. Hast du Pech gehabt.
Und die Sache ist... Gut, das ist jetzt bei diesen Song-per-Song-Downloads natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, dass du dir wirklich nur die Sachen runterlädst, die du haben willst. Das heißt, im Gegensatz zu einer normalen CD, wo dich zwei, drei Songs interessieren und der Rest eigentlich nicht so besonders interessiert, kannst du da halt eine ganz konkrete Auswahl treffen, was meiner Meinung nach auch den Preis beeinflusst.
Aber hören muss ich sie doch. Ich muss mir das doch erstmal anhören, um herauszufinden, ob mir das gefällt. Jetzt haben wir 260 Millionen Songs auf dem Server. Bis ich die durchgehör, da wäre ich alt und grau. Da gehe ich lieber in den Laden meines Vertrauens und sage, hey, du kennst mich, spiel mir mal was vor, was mir gefällt.
Wir haben da vielleicht noch ganz kurz eine Sache, die zum Beispiel beim Move-In natürlich besser ist als bei der Telekom. Wir haben einen virtuellen Einkaufsberater, bei dem man nach Attributen suchen kann. Du kannst sagen, ich will zum Beispiel intime Musik. Haben, für intime Stunden zu zweit. Und das soll aus dem Bereich Techno kommen.
Und ein bisschen Agent, ja.
Ist das Software oder ist es nicht Software?
Das ist Software.
Dabei ist es so undenkbar, dass ich irgendwann, also ich sehe das wirklich im Vergleich mit Platten, ist es so undenkbar, dass ich nachher auf einem Server, der mir Musik anbietet, nicht auch Leute tatsächlich habe, die mir Sachen empfehlen. Ich meine, ich finde es zum Beispiel im Buchbereich irgendwie durchaus nicht unspannend. Man kann sich darauf nicht verlassen, aber wenn ich ein Buch kaufe und da drunter steht, drunter Leute, die dieses Buch gekauft haben, haben auch folgende Bücher gekauft, das ist schon mal ein Start. Also da kann ich es automatisieren. Und wenn ich dann noch einen Verkäufer hätte, der wirklich Ahnung hat, dem ich vertraue, dann ist das okay. Und ich denke auch, dass dieses Downloaden und so kann immer nur ein Teil bereich sein. Ich glaube, dass Platten denen nicht so eine Angst haben müssen.
Johnny, du kannst zwei Sachen einfach mal gut betrachten, die so ähnliche Entwicklungen gehabt haben. Der erste sind erstmal die Banken. Und die Leute, die da Aktien gehandelt haben, da konnte man sich bei den Banken beraten lassen. Und da hat man dann 1% Provision gezahlt. Und jetzt gibt es Discount Broker, da zahlt man 40% Provision, kriegt keine Beratung und es geht auch noch schneller. Und die Leute haben weniger Personaldecke. Und deswegen alles viel billiger und schneller und toller. Und die setzen sich durch. Die anderen Banken haben gerade Probleme. Und die anderen Entwicklungen, wo sowas genau passiert, das sind die Computer-Leben gewesen. Da war das nämlich so, dass man am Anfang Beratung gekriegt hat. Und die haben den PC zusammengebaut. Und wenn du den gerne in Gelb getönt haben wolltest, haben die ihn gelb getönt für dich. Und dafür war der eben teuer. Und dann gab es WoBis. Da war das billig und ohne Beratung. Und dann haben die Leute sich bei den teuren Läden beraten lassen und bei WoBis gekauft. Und deswegen kann das nicht funktionieren.
Ja, das ist natürlich die traurige Wahrheit wahrscheinlich.
Personal.
Jo, was würdest du für einen Song ausgeben? Und hast du noch eine Frage an uns?
Ja, ja. Ich hab vielleicht mit dem Spiel eingeschaltet, aber ich hab hier so eine CD, die kann ich einfach nicht kopieren. Also da sagt der CD-Leser hier, nö, da ist kein Medium inserted und so. Ja halt, ich hab ja ein Amiga, aber nee, das liegt einfach am CD-Raumlaufwerk. Der sagt einfach, also ich lese das auch mit dem CD-Brenner ein, er sagt einfach, kein Medium, das ist also nicht drin. Und zwar Radiohead, okay Computer, sagt er einfach, also der Titel sagt es schon, ja?
Okay Computer, nee.
Irgendwer Abortcomputer, tja, was sollen wir denn da jetzt tun?
Nein, ich dachte, die hat das Thema schon, dass da irgendwie ein Software-Method, ein Lesesperrer eingebaut ist.
Ja, es gibt einen Kopierschutz natürlich, aber eigentlich in einem Rechner als Datenkopierer, habe ich noch nie gemerkt.
Also der CD-Brenner macht schon schlapp, das ist ein normales Ding, so ein Unit Packer-Teil hier, weiß ich nicht, so ein älterer CD-Brenner, der sagt, da ist nichts drin.
Also gut, vielleicht muss ich es mal mit einem anderen Laufweg probieren.
Oder versuch es mal mit einer anderen CD.
Oder schick eine Mail an question.nord.com.
Gut, danke euch erstmal. Bis dann, tschau.
Ist euch eigentlich klar geworden, dass hier alle bereit sind, sich für 50 Mark 5 Stunden mit Musik berieseln zu lassen? Also wenn ich 5 Stunden Musik hören will, so was am Tag irgendwie normal ist, was so aus dem Radio kommt, da zahlen die hier 50 Mark für?
Nee, ich finde, du mischst immer zwei Sachen.
Ja, aber wo ist der Unterschied? Hey, erklär mir mal den Unterschied.
Der Unterschied ist der, dass du in einem Radio eine Musikredaktion hast, dass ein Radio sich in den häufigsten Fällen durch Werbeeinnahmen finanziert und daher von ganz anderen Mechanismen gesteuert wird, als deine private Musikauswahl. Und wenn du eine CD kaufst, dann zahlst du im Moment 25 oder sagen wir mal 20 bis 35 Mark dafür. Und im Radio hörst du Musik unter ganz anderen Voraussetzungen. Radio kannst du nicht mit Musik kaufen vergleichen.
Wer sagt denn, dass es in der Zukunft nicht Radio gibt, wo ich anrufe und sage, was ich haben will? Ist das die Appetit wie im Moment? Erstens und zweitens, auf der CD habe ich auch nicht die Auswahl. Ich koch ständig CDs, weil ein Lied im Radio lief und cool war. Na gut, ich gehe von jetzt an zum Uhrweg. Aber beides ist kein gültiges Argument in meinen Augen. Also das Radio wird es sicher geben. Und dann habe ich das Problem, dass ich die Werbung gerne in Kauf nehme. Das mache ich im Moment auch. Dann gehe ich halt pinkeln, wenn das Werbung läuft. Und dann komme ich zurück und habe meine Musik aufgenommen am Abend.
Es wird trotzdem massig Leute geben, die nicht bei einem Radio anrufen wollen und sagen wollen, ich möchte gern dies und das hören, sondern die sich gerne ab und zu von einem Radio-Programm überraschen lassen, die eine redaktionelle Auswahl wollen von Leuten, die sich viel mit Musik beschäftigen. Das ist ja auch prima, will ich ja auch.
Es ist mir auch viel lieber, als auf so einem Server wie Move-A-Bit irgendwie stundenlang rumklicken zu müssen.
Ich muss suchen, ob die die Audio-On-Demand... Ich finde da eigentlich nichts für die Schlechtes dran. Das wird vielleicht nur jeder seine Meinung nochmal verstehen lassen können.
Ich möchte mal grundsätzlich was sagen. Erstens, der Plattenladen mit der guten individuellen Beratung, der wird auch in was weiß ich wann noch existieren, weil es wird immer irgendwelche Datenträger geben. Und Herrgott sei es, MP3, Speicherchips, die ich mir da kaufe, was solls. Datenträger, ob das ein CD ist oder ein Venue, ist völlig egal. Also Plattenladen wird es weiterhin geben, völlig klar.
Das sieht ganz anders aus.
Steiner und Gäntz in Zukunft, das ist gut.
Nein, wozu Speicherchips? Ist doch Unfug. Da wird es einen Bereich geben, da gehst du hin, da gibt es einen Café, da kannst du dich gemütlich unterhalten. Und der erzählt dir, er ist ein Musikberater, der verkauft dir nichts mehr. Den traust du dafür, dass er dich berät.
Ich sollte mal eine halbe Stunde mit Herrn Stein von Gartelsmann in eine Zelle stecken.
Liebe Chaos-Radio-Hörer, wie ihr merkt, ist die Streitkultur beim Chaos Computer Club immer noch sehr ausgeprägt.
In der Zukunft ist es doch für Streiten, aber das ist ja was Positives.
Wir empfinden ja den Streit auch als was Positives und daraus gibt es sozusagen neue Kraft.
Ich wollte auch sagen, dass es vor ein paar Jahren in einer Wired mal einen interessanten Artikel zum Thema Finanzierung von audiovisuellen Medien durch Werbung gegeben hat. Da wurde nämlich gesagt, hey, ist das eigentlich schon längst andersrum? Ich werde mit Features, Musik und Filmen dafür belohnt, dass ich mir Werbung angucke.
Was ich eigentlich damit ausdrücken wollte, ist, dass die Sendung jetzt zu Ende ist. Und dass wir sozusagen Chaos-Radio wieder zusammenfalten für einen Monat. Ich aber trotzdem nochmal darauf hinweisen wollte, dass wir einen. Eine Mailing-Liste haben die Chaos-Radio-Ticker, der immer die Ankündigung für die nächsten Sendungen schickt und der, wie ich hoffe, ab dieser Sendung auch endlich wieder nach der Sendung, ein versprochene Feedback sendet. Wir haben ja hier diverse URLs zusammengetragen, die werde ich dann nachher posten. Da kann man sich eintragen. Dann gibt es noch das Chaos-Update, das ist auch eine Mailing-Liste, die ähnlich funktioniert für All-Things-Chaos, nochmal für die Leute, die sich später eingeschaltet haben, die man später einsammelt. Der Chaos-Communication-Kongress wird auch dieses Jahr wieder stattfinden, und zwar zur Überraschung von allen, dieses Mal in Berlin. Genaueres dazu finden Sie sich dann auch in der Chaos-Update-Mailing-Liste beziehungsweise auf unserem Webserver www.ccc.de Das war Chaos-Radio, gleich geht es weiter mit einem Nightflight mit Martin Petersdorf.
Ich bedanke mich bei Sascha Ziembusch und Sascha Siebenmong von Moveabit, die lange hier gesessen haben. Und natürlich beim Chaos Computer Club, die jeden letzten Mittwoch um 100 lange hier sitzen.
Wir bedanken uns natürlich auch bei dir, Johnny.
Ganz toll, danke. Ach, ich mach's gerne.
Ich mach's gerne, ich bin so drauf. Ich krieg dafür Geld und mach's gerne.
Wir bedanken uns ganz besonders bei den Hörern, die es doch echt bis jetzt noch ausgehalten haben.
Genau, wir lieben euch alle.